une production du studio sfr bienvenue
aux 100 foot
le podcast où on parle de ce qu'on veut
avec nos invités date chez hays et si
c'était quoi
c'est un mec se dope sa grâce à faire
longtemps qu'on fait ça je peux que les
gens s'ennuient et mais ça n'ira pas
l'extrader semaines et mois qui a prêté
avec moi de dôme plantes
cette semaine avant qu'on fasse notre
petite annonce juste un challenge parce
qu'en fin de semaine j'étais au
casse-croûte saint-girons avec ma blonde
pour présenter nos maîtres surgelés
veillant n'est pas plate puis le nombre
de personnes qui sont venus me parler du
sans-fil podcasts ou qui me féliciter
pour le podcast qui me dit qu écouter le
podcast
ça me touche profondément ça nous touche
profondément
il ya même un gars qui est venu voir qui
me dit aymen ça fait bizarre de devoir
pendant que je t'écoute et qui m'ont
montré qu'ils écoutent et n'être pas de
gaza guillaume wagner jalade à toi même
tu en as tu as tout le monde qui sont
venus nous voir pour me voir en fait
pendant le week end
puis puissant vous on ferait pas de
podcasts
même toit d'un petit fed fait parler du
parc as beaucoup je te raconte pas ce
que c'est faux il faisait chaud
d'abord un événement privé leurs pattes
et de bureaux du temps des fêtes avec
moi mon groupe de musique qu'on fait des
faits sur d'affaires felton connu le
moment de gloire c'est quand que je
lâche la guitare puis je prend le maquis
puis les cheveux la meilleur tonneau
monde
je n'attaque pas de casque puis mais il
ya des gens sont venus d'après me voir
puis m'ont dit qu'il y avait peut-être
votre casque mais vraiment ça ça fait
toujours plaisir ça fait plaisir de lire
vos commentaires bien sûr plaisir de
vous sentir présent mais quand vous
venez me voir en live qu'on veut croiser
c'est vraiment le fun de voir qu'on
quitte vraiment qui existe qui nous
écoutent puisque vous existez vous
comprenez ce que je dis est ce
maintenant aussi on tient à remercier
nos sponsors pour l'épisode
d'aujourd'hui
premièrement écolo fitness et que nos
fenêtres cmj méconnaissent et le jam de
dôme vient chaque année et que
l'abonnement platine puis que j'ai accès
à leur 70e au québec
donc peu importe kyushu souvent sa route
ma famille ta québec j'avais à montréal
donc je peux aller
green day au jam n'importe quand et ont
des cours de groupe du bénin guillon des
cours de l'aérobie ont des courbes de
coureurs de groupe et ont même un
circuit d'entraînement de 30 minutes
pour les gens plus pressés vous pouvez
choisir votre programme d'entraînement
selon vos objectifs il ya un lion de
l'hydromassage lyon du bronzage et ont
vraiment tout ce que vous voulez dans un
gym
ils l'ont dans le nord ont fait cirer un
abonnement platine ou écolo finesse donc
ce que vous avez besoin de faire vous
allez dans la description du podcast
vous cliquez sur le lien qui va être là
vous inscrivez votre nom de famille
votre prénom et votre nom de famille
avec votre adresse courriel
on va dévoiler le gagnant lors de
l'épisode du 3 décembre et le concours
va se finir le 26 novembre donc
une bonne façon de commencer votre
nouvelle année du bon pied
allez participer à ce concours l'appui
mercier a comme jeunesse de encourager
le podcast
yes deuxième commanditaire le podcast
droit ciu qui est une start up qui te
compagnie québécoise et montréalaise on
les a rencontrés sont super gentils ils
ont une super bonne idée avec la
plateforme comment ça marche
là dessus les autres font affecte
plusieurs boutiques qui voit là dessus
une plateforme une boutique un panier du
dans le fond il ya des look là dessus du
genre dit vraiment moi pis toile et
n'importe qui qui met son look sur la
plateforme
et puis quand même un look back peut
l'acheter en entier avec les différents
morceaux qui viennent de différentes
différentes boutiques sépare le fun moi
même j'ai applaudi un look deux looks
même surgissent ue cherche aussi un peu
dans le sahara qui mélo qui sont très
populaires voix les plus populaires que
les looks de ph sans aucune surprise
parce que même aujourd'hui on porte no
look du ratio puis comme vous pouvez
voir moi je suis un gars plutôt
traditionnelle jam sournois retrait
confortable de 8 ans soudeur ou gimpu
l'incroyable un pull c'est un pull c'est
un pull un croyant un peu l'incroyable
ouais donc pis si vous achetez sur just
you pouvez ensuite vous même
téléchargez vos looks sur la plateforme
puis après ce que vous êtes un fait un
pourcentage sur les ventes 1 5%
tout ce qui est vendu chaque fois que
votre look est vendu vous recevez un 5 %
des profits
moi j'ai reçu un beau petit virement
avec ce smartphone alors une belle belle
initiative belle plate formes
compliquées des causes vous encourager
aussi l'achat local parce qu'ils font
affaire avec des compagnies québécoises
alors encouragé les mais surtout des
voix puissante magazine est là parce que
c'est tellement plus simplement plus
fort et s exactions cette semaine
donnent tous en fait cette semaine on a
reçu roxane bruno c'est sa deuxième
apparition sous le casque
on réinvente comme sono nos invités
chouchou elle en fait partie est drôle
et attachante est magnifique et
talentueuse surtout est allé gagné le
félix de la chanson de l'année avec des
petits bouts de toit au dernier gala de
l'adisq un prix monstrueusement un
énorme cri un prix énorme qui est venu
ici vu le moins d'un an
sa carrière était loin d'être aussi
fulgurante qu'elle l'est présentement
alors on la félicite puisse toujours un
plaisir de la voir
c'est une belle conversation qu'ont eu
sur toute cette affaire sur la musique
sur la vie sur les troubles de t d dont
elle est atteinte atteintes de maladies
dont puis dont je ne suis finalement pas
attendre
j'ai appris c'est officiellement
d'affaires et donc je vous dis que je
t'ai déjà je le suppose je suis même pas
ok mais c'est s'attaquer
encore un gros plaisir d'avoir eu accès
non la remercie - sinon dans notre
dernier petites annonces
on a reformé de pétulance la plateforme
de sociaux financement ou est-ce que
vous pouvez le plus directement nous
encourager on a enlevé les paliers
monétaire on a tout mis à 3 $ donc si
vous voulez vous abonner la paix tout en
maintenant ses trois pièces vous allez
avoir accès à tous nos podcasts oxo
stock pardon qui sont tournés donc on
remet ça aussitôt que les patients sont
au plus haut de 1 2 pour l'instant qui
sont sur la plateforme qui ont vu que
personne peut y avoir accès sauf nos
membres et ron ensuite on va enregistrer
des podcasts juste une deux ou est-ce
qu'on va jaser demain une excellente
détente au reer en parler oui non mais
sur le bitume non répond aux questions
de nos auditeurs de nos fans de nos coco
comme jackson factice des questions mais
del un commentaire aussi puis on va
répondre sinon platon pitchoune voie à
toutes vos questions de notre podcast
exclusif - est exact sinon vous écoutez
présentement sur peu importe la
plateforme en fait sur laquelle vous
nous écoutez c'est super important
support apprécier si vous me laissez un
commentaire par rapport à la discussion
les seynois writing times up
un cinq étoiles ça fait son bout de
chemin ce n'est pas la plus de monde
d'écouter le sans-fil puissant le monde
qui complaît sans fil qui a pas de sans
filtre donc merci la guerre sans vous on
n'est rien sans vous on est riche mais
c'est vrai j'ai littéralement s'envoler
rien sans vous le sans-fil triés sur ces
sages paroles bon podcast bonne écoute
[Musique]
avec ça les regarde et merci de revenir
sur le paquet ça me plaisait vos studios
son écart la merci des coûts merci
beaucoup ça fait plaisir d'entendre ça
c'est adamo qui apparaît oui je suis
tout elle avait reconnu ses toiles
hoyé choc qui est en fait d'un gros je
sais pas quel point ben t'es tu n'as tu
es tu dans le marché pour une peinture
chinoise n'encaisse pas taillé dans le
fond parce que moi j'ai des plafonds de
12 pipe c'est tout blanc
ils ont commencé à déménager ou un plomb
comment ça m'a dit stop maison j'ai
acheté un blush capote parce que jean
mon salon cuisine le siamu relais finit
plus près de 70 deux fois longs comme
votre nom c'est terrible chinoises ont
coûté quelques points dont on ne saura
jamais pourquoi avec un vieux du monde
qui s'en est pas la venger j'avais
jamais dit ou je restais puis je
recevais des florentine motorola qui me
suivait s'est pas dopé les fans les plus
intenses os en quelque chose mais c'est
parce qu'il est maintenant je dis
toujours la même chose 95% sont parfaits
ils sont agressifs mais juste qu'il faut
maintenant pour me faire greffer les
créateurs succès puis elle les 5% qui
prend schiste mathon la ligne de
l'acceptable et c'est par amour mais
troll - dean dont mais non dit nous
savons pour ouvrir one qui on accorde ma
classe exactement
mais j'en parlais je demande mais johnny
était correct d'autre part creuser pour
ce roi des enfants proposés malaisiens
sont tellement un amour avec mon couple
il ya du respect pour moi je me fais 0
crouzil qui coule ouais bah ça dépasse
des fois ça fait mal ça tant attendu
ouais parce qu'en plus
apparemment la communauté lgbt sont en
baisse et il m'était respectueux et
lesbiennes à qui je parle plus parce que
je t'ai comme mon du site étaient 1 go
en ce moment la question sexuelle santé
mais bon avec stephlyon on en parle
comme paul mais je me suis dit au panier
souvent des amies lesbiennes acheter
quand la fille hétéro avec l'art marié
savoir en ce moment leur classement
huawei je peux pas gérer ça mais ça ça
me met trop mal c'est que les enfants
les plus 8 qui est des fans et ans ont
fait le même temps là et d'amélie
florentine mon châssis ça m'a vraiment
fait pas beaucoup mieux
we have and let en abyme le parce qu'on
t'aime
je reçois des poèmes je reçois des
grosses déclaration d'amour dans mon
pantalon mais non pas d'amour mais des
déclarations de jean tu as sauvé ma vie
je suis agacé toute ma jeunesse mois
gilles sap respectée puisque c'est rohff
à eau et des cci se confie à moin lé
vraiment comme si j'étais à leur sort le
petit peu à bord 100% confiance à mort
en même temps que je vais pas lire leur
lit tu peux dire leur nom l'âge ils
peuvent le faire confiance au fca c'est
comme c'est intense le camping est ce
que c'est plus
c'est plus les fans qui t'ont connu met
à table il faut arrêter des fans c'est
vraiment un mot qui me lie caucus les
cocos s'était enfoncé les cocos qui
t'ont connu par le web bouaké ben je
sais pas parce que tant attendu à radio
maintenant les médias traditionnels ont
apporté une autre vague de cocoa si
bizarre du chantier nature
oui c'est exactement mon premier tout le
monde en parle normalement tu peux
marcher tout le monde en parle c'est fou
cette émission c'est fou l'adisq ou si
c'est drôle parce que le lendemain de
l'adisq moyens le sepa la porte son nom
cet arc et le lendemain c'est écrit
comme le lendemain de l'adisq et je m'en
veux voir le show de mike ward parce que
moi j'ai christine le racisme au
quotidien revient donc sur mike wallace
pour la partie je m'envole ou avec ma
blonde guidée au dix30 jalil plein
d'entrées sorties entre les magasins
ferment ou je roule tranquille parce que
je dans le stationnement beer goya rift
me couper iru les gens 70 ce qui sort de
nulle part
pas que je klaxonne est vraiment
j'embauche klaxons the object composent
ce groupe aussi jeune kopeck montchamp
mais il bonne en arrière de mobiles fait
comme il fait une fine de me rentrer
dedans mais je sais pas ce qui s'est
passé je n'ai pas beaucoup dormi et j'ai
comme qu'ils enbridge sortie de mon job
je suis sorti c'est comme vivre cette
fois c'est la maladie ce qui la met ou
surlendemain ça venait d'arriver
c'est d'ailleurs là non
ha ha ha ha ha compte mais témoin le
shanti guan genre patrimoine à klaus est
comme mille fois trop gros pour moi ce
moment ce que j'ai fait pour sortir il
faut que je me donnais mon swing
maintenant rage et je me met à crier
gens après le gauche peut même pas de
vue que j'ai crié mais le ghost est une
pièce l'élite est comme dans un pick up
mais après ça j'ai compté mon homme de
gauche je peux pas écrire les boys yb a
sorti c'est comme il me faisait
seulement c'était fini pour moi je vais
te vicious cycle de l'eau mondial de
gauche est à peu près la chef de groupe
i a fait pour moi je vois un enfant
grosses comme tout sortir de son chant
je ne saurais de tous ces soldats en
armes jamais quand je regarde ça canarde
le che guérilla prêt à titiller justice
afin que vous aurez comme était vraiment
malade ma blonde tout ce qu'elle faisait
yartey l'adisq le monde à la voile sur
tout le monde te connais c'est bon ça
c'est bon c'est pas ta carrière
aujourd'hui maman considération la
journaliste journal marianne qui fait le
bateau on est chanceux de travailler
c'est vraiment je me rappelle projet qu
il ya vraiment un
un autre niveau de célébrité
souhaitons au québec le même les gens
les plus connus au québec c'est jean
louis qui avait un marché sur le plateau
sans se faire chier le 18 mai comme il
ya un autre niveau le niveau brad pitt
ou est-ce que peu importe qui est aussi
matière à la casse sera pas fermée
toutfou la boule sont toutes passées
c'est normal je pense pas qu'un être
humain est physiquement fait pour ce
métier ils font un faux peau avec un
paparazzi en a mais parce qu'ils sont
écoeurés qualifia l'os libre qui gère
ce qui la donne et puis que comme 12 ans
de presse qu'il faut pour gérer ce non
plus car dépendant fin humain pas été
créé pour ce surtout pas les enfants et
11,0 bagages et aux changements aux 30m
je pense pas que j'aie la maturité pour
briser ce que je vis en ce moment
imaginez quand à 12 ans dans le monde
oui et en arrière et d'avoir faim de 12
ans il ya un parent pas trop conscient
non plus de ce qui se passe qui est
juste commencer enfin à bon compte et
par an
c'est fou quand ils pensent à mézin mais
en tout cas tu remarqué j'imagine que
depuis l'adisq même avancé depuis ton
premier de ma part que tu parlais un
switch grand dans la façon que les gens
voient je me dis que les gens te
reconnaissent mêlant plus sépare
toujours partout où est-ce que tu
veuilles a aucune place que tu te mettes
on ne peut pas sortir de chez vous ça ne
ferait quand même manqué une fois
tabarnak
ouais quand même c'est fou ça c'est ça
c'est tout le monde en parle la dernière
année je pense que c'est le slicepad
tout ensemble ça maintenant j'ai fait
beaucoup dans la dernière année j'ai
fait beaucoup de trucs en commun mais
qui donne un boost en carrière et
maintenant j'ai fait le show la saint
jean baptiste à montréal il s'est
tellement de monde qui avait aucune dit
que j'étais qui ont fait vingt ans qu'il
s'est elle la petite s'est passé cela to
sky encore des bas de caisse qu'on avait
fait ensemble pour m'habiller par et
fige l'arrivée de red steel bouton on
disait sûr que les gens connaissaient ma
chanson mais la face sur la chanson le 1
cette année en fait je suis maintenant
sur la chance est passée juste avant
qu'on se mette à tourner je te demandais
si cardon était venu parce que depuis
devenu s'est fait moins de reina ça a
changé du tout au tout oui ça a vraiment
changé mais je me plais à dire que c'est
suite à ton passage à intel numéro 32 ça
fait pas
ouais c'est vrai timide même à l'époque
où si tu disais que tu te sentais encore
plus la route ça et nous de ce monde le
devant de la musique mais pensait voir
et passion encore reçu le premier
l'adisq après premier l'a10 je disais
mais je mentais en fait à tout le monde
en disant non j'ai pu syndrome de
l'imposteur parce que j'étais écoeuré
d'être celle qui fait pitié ils sont
nombreux un peu en pitié quand je dis ça
mais c'était vraiment folle je lis
ressenti quand je suis allé à la 10
cette année c'est le tapis rouge des
colis encore c'est encore le suis
éternelle en coin j'en suis vraiment
comme encore dans vie comme le smoking
je déteste ça puis c'est le tapis rouge
tu es un peu sur wayne non mais c'est
vrai et puis c'est juste si j'ai répété
la même chose tout le long du tapis
rouge même temps la petite roxane ans -
étaient comme cette année les médiaux
ils veulent me parler de l'année passée
c'était mon attachée de presse qui tout
comme maxime grenon la chanson ce pas
stressé à qui il voulait me parler le
style comme tout et bien c'est on veut
parler c'est soit ça me faisait du bien
parce que je suis reconnu dans le milieu
où je voulais être le plus reconnu et
aimé le fait dit la chanson de l'année
c'est comme un des plus durs aller
chercher mais oui enfin ça c'est joli
pull le salon important et c'est vrai
elle
et puis je le rsa j'ai ma place qui à
travers les autres artistes mettront à
la distance en toute sympathie de la
gagne pain ça ça n'est pas un conte
d'impôt compte mais face à kobe lui
mettant un terme et on m'a remis chaque
fois quand on croise since they want
c'est la même personne avec moins c'est
la même dans le temps où je commençais
elle je suis aussi assez vu en moi
l'espèce de marginal qui arrive avec son
nouveau stock marni stade du nouveau
stock le drapeau personnes avaient fait
chaud avant et québec fait c'est la
bonne mais oui c'est quoi chantre
marie-mai a way to tatou et langues
possibles göteborg
[Rires]
meiway fac a toujours été super gentil
avec moi un pied a toujours été de bon
conseil puis quand j'ai reçu de refaire
pression des eaux partait pas venu me
vois bien maudit pour vrai chaque année
et des trophées on se dit pourquoi ils
s'en vont
le monde comprend pas pourquoi les trois
fils ramos luis ramos mais cela y est
dans les bonnes mains il devait allaiter
qu'ils arrêtent de le prendre par la
taille ramos les par les mains parce
qu'ils roulent d'expérience à ce calibre
un saxo bank
la rue monte tranquillement face à elle
le temps les bras mais tenait à ce
milieu là j'ai l'impression qu'il ramène
comme quelques instances de légitimité
qui sont sont plus importantes que les
autres pays je crois que quand quand guy
à
themba ça donne un instit push attendant
forme parce que tu es à ton premier
passage à tout le monde en parle
clairement d'un coup de coeur de
guillaume et avait été tellement faim
ouais c'est même après à divion rester
nous dit je vois toujours regretter
d'avoir dit non j'ai dit non 2 il m'a
dit viens on reste avec nous bien manger
avec nous que j'ai fait ce qui était le
sait la première fois on a un code
y'avait alexandre ce soit toujours me
rappeler parce qu'il y avait tellement
été fait avec et moi en coulisses qui
comme il mettait comme en confiance il
me faisait sentir que j'avais ma place
dans un club parce que j'ose avec moi
mais les autres le font moi j'ai peur
quand je tournais redouble y vraiment
c'est pourquoi refuser et j'avais refusé
parce que je commençais à être malade
pour un changement toujours malade
mousser l'enfant puis j'avais des
spectacles comme la fin de semaine
d'après qui s'en venait leur faim je
vais me reposer le plus possible parce
que je trouve la mutuelle du combattant
avoir eu l'écho et d'y aller je réalise
malades pas mal rien à [ __ ]
allô oui mais oui j'avais dit non tu
m'avais dit
avant de sortir un deuxième album puis
tout va revenir à pour cas ce deuxième
album vrai ça s'en vient on travaille là
dessus du matelas mon réalisateur qui
t'ont guitariste c'est drôle parce que
matt c'est comme son premier succès à
lui cité il y avait beaucoup de gays
gaven mais comme il réalisait pas placez
vraiment de son premier album qui
réalise avec quelqu'un racing en chanson
de l'année oui c'est pas une bonne
première geek de m
c'est tellement une première grille de
contrôle même pas peur
bref si c'est drôle parce qu'elle
mastaing cpcca - ma introverti bas prix
génie st avec 600 cas comme sa place
mais moyens sa place c'est pis que la
monte c'est pas parce que je sais pas si
c'est comme ça dans toutes les milieux
parce que c'est je suis pas je connais
beaucoup d'humoristes mais je fais pas
partie du milieu le mot vraiment je peux
dans la galerie tout mais on me dit que
les gens disent qu'ils sont contents
mais bof tu es maintenant entre artistes
en tête d'affiche tron va se délasser
bon félicitations tout mais un musicien
bns je sais pas si tu leur sang to pass
tig et gossip pas mal mais comme on
dirait qu'à une compétition malsaine et
mathieu des musiciens qui regardent
s'asseoit vote a foiré bouvry un matelas
il s'est pas tu as fait des
félicitations par les autres personnes
par dessus du monde que récemment les
gens qui font j'aurais pu france ses
notes sans fouiller pas j'aimerais ça
que les gens disent merci ou pas merci
mais qui jadis félicitations fait mais
c'est moins de tâches comme ils méritent
tellement d'espoir dit props les caméras
des gens qui sont ni faire des études
commenta genre est thérapeute août est à
la hauteur de ton dernier succès demain
le soir de la diffusion il y avait le
trac montbernage xs et lui c'est comme
l'agro jalousie plâtre j'ai l'impression
que tu mets ton d'un milieu du rap c'est
comment il ya toute l'espèce de
de props à l'équipe son drake s'est pas
dit cependant les autres milieux
nécessairement c'est peut-être parce que
moi je faisais j'ai reçu la chanson de
la ligne j'ai fait des remerciements y
avait eu spectacle année j'ai une amie
mais mon gars tu sembles les auteurs
compositeurs font pas monter leur aurait
alors que l'oréal sur les states et ce
comme pas des moeurs
ouais parce que tout comme la route qui
arrive avec ses 2 ces deux outils of pi
wallon je sais que je suis bon je me
suis même pas posé la question du
pourquoi du commun mais moi je sais que
mon attachée leprest mon équipe m'ont
dit ça serait multi mans justement parce
que la face on veut vraiment être
ensemble pour ça aussi mais c'est un
matin j'ai réglé spectacle l'année gérer
fait monter la sauce et sam et remercie
master jusqu'au godisson on l'attaché de
presse le trac en radio j tout mille
parce que je voulais être sûr de
remercier tout le monde parce que pour
moi chanson de l'année
si mclaren c'est ce jeudi matin c'est le
pays comme c'est à tourner c'est trop
facile comme fo kaufmann et taghit en
avoir été vraiment pas bonne chanson là
jamais pensé à radio comme ça se finisse
si c'était pas de mal
et il ya une raison pour laquelle marie
m'est venue de voir bientôt grand
féliciter comme ceux puisqu'elle s'est
reconnue c'est que titre quand même
temps quand même à l'adisq drame dans le
monde d'un paysage mettons des artistes
au québec
1.6 de gauche puis les artistes pop
latine puis j'ai l'impression que le
tchèque l'eau depuis un jeu lotfi que ça
se mélange pas de difficulté avec la
droite au cas par cas je fais ça ça veut
dire l'air mais si j'ai vraiment
beaucoup de difficultés parce que moi
c'est c'est les êtres humains c'est
comme quand tu mens foule s'était droite
ou de gauche ou pour qu'ils tuent volent
mais parfois c'est ce que je trouve ça
plate des les étiquettes ont jusque là
on nie toute l'europe les artistes on
veut pas risquer dans le padd dans des
causes finalement
soto crise là devant justement parce que
oui tu as raison mais les artistes mais
ces pics à droite gauche parle même pas
de lagence politique par juste mettons
de non j'avais qu'on a peut être dans
n'importe quoi la droite que la gauche
c'est juste que - je trouve sa place ce
mois-ci mettons je m'attends du bar on
pense à cuba on voit ceux des ice a lu
ça vaut mais comme jamais on va être
portée à aller prendre un thé ensemble
comment parce qu'on est tellement
dépareillé que par tout le monde
jean même l'immédiat tout le monde sait
comment jamais on va penser à faire un
ouais une espèce de blaine aux pays bas
c'est tellement tu vois über je trouve
que par exemple sur quelque chose sur
quelqu'un que vous rejoignez si le désir
d'avoir un succès populaire
tu es ubaye est pas si élitiste dans ce
sens que je moi je fais mon art puis si
les gens comprennent pas c ôté pays bas
c'est comme moi je fais de la musique
pour le peuple
un peu comme toi mais pour exactement la
même peuple mais tombe c'est ça ce qui
vous met des transports urbains eu une
espèce de transformation cette année les
gens vraiment utile années passées je
sentais qu'il y avait une partie lui qui
voulait que choquer ouais j'ai adhéré
potasse
j'ai un jardin à s'amuser que j'adore
google qui tous et pas uniquement au
cloud com - dans le fond mais son espèce
de quota
comme pour juste faire parler mon jardin
passe pendant toute cette année on l'a
senti switchers peut vraiment j'ai eu un
gros 360 les gens disent or d'après moi
il s'est fait par les eaux que non il
s'est pas fait par le bas et personne ne
peut parler mais moi le costaud qui
j'essaie de me dire coiffage comme un
mon dieu on dirait que j'ai envie de
faire tout le contrat juteux franchir
deux fois que j'ai pas de patron en
ville c'est exactement pour ça que je
fais de la musique s'est pas fait parler
d'eux je parle de rigueur et justice est
exactement il ya juste fait ok le joint
au changement je peux me calmer les gens
c'est bon c'est comme ici c'est quand il
présentait la catégorie à l'adisq
tellement nos petits bleus s'étaient
foule
jean ouimet du bascom se distinguent
gneto une trop poli trop gentil il
travaille à hisser son image publique
c'est pour lui les gorilles et parce
qu'on pense qui tient c'est ça justement
c'est en fait un groupe
une pac est fait je m'en sors fait la
tour qui a lieu service et c'est le
service hicham a mais il est
complètement un contrôle de ce qui fait
passer sa blanc sont sages et quand le
poète à contrôler des skiffs est
totalement au québec est pas vraiment un
seul nom non sûrement pas sur ma peau
prend le maquis du monde prend le maquis
est que des jeux j'ai aucun exemple qui
mue entamée par roman qui croivent
probable qu'il ya des créations qui sont
plus voué à vendre des albums j'ai
l'impression que mes tonka dessus quand
tu sors mettons deux avec la botte de
star académie le web sso message avant
je pense à ce point quand sort des
lapins que le ton album c'est pas la
chose qui te représente le plus le dire
non mais je pense quand même qu'il ya
une petite différence en job le 10 15
ans quatre académies c'est un produit le
plus y avait là bas coût sur le stand
des amis ou en fait le septième art
musique ensemble dire que gagner qu'il
n'y en a qu'un qui gagne quelques rares
academy le ft com qui te porte ce oui ce
site et on sait ce qui attend on paye un
entraîneur privé y on paye un styliste
qui tu étais au genre tout est géré pour
tous les québécois ça marche mais bordel
ici c'est le modèle céline le quai tout
comme le gérant omniprésent qui décide
de tout en arrière le toit
c'est ce prix de comment il ya encore
des gens qui pensent que gérer un
artiste comme ça ça fonctionne moi j'ai
pu donner de petits coups bas qui ont
déjà une équipe mais j'ai pas de jeu pas
des gens j'en ai eu au début ça n'a pas
fonctionné on s'est quittés puis j'ai eu
quelqu'un pendant un an avec moi comme
sous contrôle qui était comme pour
replacer parce que ça allait trop vite
fac on le mit dans le clip pour replacer
tout qu'est ce qui était en train de
s'effondrer parce que je sais pas
comment dire trop vite trop haut et plus
ça c'était comme un gros 20 qui partait
de la toiture le fa cup elle solidifie
tout se met le jeu réalise qui
j'ai une grosse équipe autour de moi
mais je cassais wild pour prendre les
décisions pour moi dans ce sens où
pendant quatre ans j'ai bild et mon truc
sur internet pige pas mal ce mec est à
cause de ça que je suis ici aujourd'hui
sûrement ouais c'est mais les maisons
traditionnelles vraiment aidé le soc est
indéniable mais il y aura des trous si
tu ne serais pas rendu aux médias
traditionnels
oui puis non you will be très terne et
moi c'est ça ces deux vagues de vagues
complètement différentes qui ont fait un
raz-de-marée n'en font vos le fou mais
c'est parce que là je me dis fuck off je
veux pas de gérants parce que c'est
comme je dis beaucoup de monde encore
qu'ils finissent pas ça c'est fou quand
je deviens signes de piasses demande si
ça m'intéresse mais les demandes qui
rend les emails qu'ils rentrent pour 6
pour ce tout jeune attaché de price
j'ai une attachée de presse j'ai mon
producteur j'ai un beau spectacle pour
chaque a faim il ya quelqu'un qui
s'occupe de tout
de combien de monde qui ferait avec toi
même ton jugé la prod
le producteur fond j'ai beaucoup de
spectacles ceci reste c'est une agence
complète de gens qui s'occupent de ce le
gorille est tellement enfin les papilles
qui s'appelle luire soul papillon fait
qu'on l'appelle firefox ou des appels à
dimanche soit way avez-vous des larges
d'un chandail jackson bruno biais comme
parce que simon si son nom est ainsi que
son numéro téléphone zéro client que hal
gill piège et au rhdp pour le tracking
radio quand j'ai envie de chansons c'est
eux qui vont partager la brouille j'ai
vu que cela rabat en toute fin de partie
elle est partie et où ses accesseurs
pour chaque soir je t'avais croître un
pur
l'attaché de presse du sarloton ben
c'est cool c'est important d'être
capable de deux délégués des trucs ou
est ce que toi mettons ça te prendrais
tout torreilles alors que eux c'est
quand même quelque chose d'autre parmi
tant d'autres a généré au début je
voulais tellement pas faire afin que
personne les gens jetaient que
demanderait de m'acheter une machine
haut à gauche
en fait j'ai acheté une machine shirt je
demanderai de le faire en fait je les
légions mais je vais faire je les fait
partager des t shirts à peu près de
samaa vip médicinales manger ça avec les
délégués pour toute la main jallet kim
compagnie s'occupe de tout mais imaginez
les vendent plus cher savent que j'ai
fait c'est le avoir commencé la tournée
tu disais que
là c'est les choix de paul roll ouais
ouais
cet été le c'est drôle parce que mon
livre a choisi presse à damas puis je me
sens mieux que je me sentais cda ouais
ouais mais pourtant d'un arbre je te
voyais encore partout au nom mais ce
parce que moussa a été rapide
je tenais voit un psy piero est vraiment
là j'ai tout prix les outils pour pas
comme ça peut-être paru un peu des
réseaux sociaux pendant un bout de cet
été et non ouais mais j'avais plus d'un
sessad rez-de-chaussée de sept chiffres
parfois du contenu web parce qu'elle est
c'est ce jeudi la guêpe ofek 9 le guide
est rendu compliqué de filmer fois le
show le sandjak à l'esprit fort les
entrevues c'était n'importe quoi fait
que j'engage les caméramans j'engagerai
caméramans lui me suit ses gains après
seulement la seule fois que je pourrai
jamais déguisé le montage je peux j'aime
trop savoir ce qu'il ya comme une touche
que si d'élections à montans savent
appareil qui se font avancer
ouais si je veux passer puisque les gens
y ont adhéré à ma chaise lorsque c'était
seul contenu fait j'essaie de toucher le
moins possible
la tournée c'est comme les musiciens qui
souffrent de dépression puis de bruno tu
à cause de la tournée si si c'est
omniprésent et oui c'est vraiment
différent parce que c'est comme une
jauge de vie drive déjà trop tard parce
que tu aimes à chaque soin puis les
jantes adultes 5 ou iphone
j'échangerais ma vie pour rien au monde
mais c'est la tournée fois du show
depuis 13 ans de chantier match à sept
îles le petit mon âme a tourné comme ses
choix sa part max et ils ont le voit pas
le monde qui se soit ils ne voient pas
tout la maria d'études attentes de
schorre annoncé full tilt foule était le
traversier puis tout petit mois je fais
de l'anxiété dans ville ait chez nous
c'est un combo déjà en partant faire
partir demain pic c'est sûr comme je
vous disais je n'avais pas de bouquet
avant la tournée a été booké comme
broche à foin au début parce que le sale
il y avait des demandes on acceptait
tout enfin qu on est descendu à sept
îles pour deux shows on est en effet
celle ci laisse coin bondir de 110 on
n'a pas fait on voit sa cote n'en
pendant deux semaines
en fait toutes les villes puis on
revient en faisant d'autres villes
parlaient en annoncer au monde 13 heures
en fait deux choix hors des centres et
légumes mais on y rentre dans le shiraz
et qui ne vendent quand même notre lit
en arrière et un écran de pv au game
face à ses côtés mais au début le sait
[Musique]
l'enfant vraiment le les conditions sur
la route sont meilleurs mais la route en
tant que tel le moins seul dans ma
taille trop longtemps c'est vraiment pas
bon pour moi
moi j'ai déjà dit tout le temps j'ai
peur j'ai une santé mentale à risque
oui vraiment faut que faut toujours que
je sois bien encore dribbles qui pour ce
que je vois je vois mme siby médicaments
illicites c'est quoi ta oui c'est un
tapis tissés bond elle dit parce qu'il
souvent un tabou avec ceux là sont des
menteurs ou encore l'on pense que non
mais il y en a encore un bon achat comme
je le dis ouvertement gay - le plus
flipper de bord n'importe quelle fasse
attention à mon avis tout change mais
ils s'essoufflent dans le temps qui est
des plus des vidéos - de chaud c'était
vraiment chez vous tout le temps chez
nous c'est déjà fait et vidéo est ici
crise - exigent que faire douze heures
de show aussi mais j'ai été un beau
célibataire ça avec eux maintenant c'est
ridicule mais comme ça me fait pas dans
son souci de seul chez nous bluffe
d'oubli de manger j'oublie de dormans
j'oublie de bois littéralement j'oublie
de pisser parce que le pouvoir qu'ont
les que je travaille je travaille je
travaille je fais du montage je fais de
la promo j ai rien que je fais peu qu'un
carreau est rentré dans ma vie alors
comme sans s'en rendre compte parce que
ses portes il ya des filles dans le
contrôle en mai les rôles - j'ai comme
rentrer dans son mode de vie où elle et
ce sur des rappeurs cloud un fake haslem
à 6 ans le matin puis alain job il ya
des morts ou est-ce que c'est fini voilà
jobs exactement chez moi je me couchais
en même temps qu'elle quand ça ça me
donne un beat de vie normale qui
reviennent travailler tard et tout ça ça
dépend
mais ça n'est pas parce que moi
maintenant je dois commencer à 9 10
heures le matin je me lèverai pas mais
des fois on me laisse la mettons kg
c'est ça la mouche pendant 4 jours
semaine
qui me reste pas grand temps pour faire
du montage puis tout le reste la fac à
melesse plancher mais envoie pauvre elle
est parfaite cette ville pourrait violer
la prime des titrailles ban trop je te
vois qu'elle met en pause à me laisse
pas mes enfants ainsi que ça me rend
heureux c'est si je me couche pas 4 5
ans dimanche
comment cette grise la fin de la tournée
pour seulement pour le sommeil pour
faire du sport pour bien manger tout ce
sac sommes pas ça prend le bord safec
telle qualité de vie python ton esprit
men devine qu'à ce moment j'avais pris
du poids
j'ai pris du projet je pourrai jamais
assez aux gens c'est comme je pourrai
jamais vraiment prendre de poids au
piquage prend du coup ça m'avait fait du
bien de prendre du repos parce que moi
j'ai trop mince avant ma main et je me
suis dit ok mais quand il faudrait s'en
sentent ils parce que quand et antony tu
manges tu es mon itunes mac donald et
martin mc donald et martin tim hortons
que moi c'est juste que tu manges tu
sais comment je vais faire des choix
santé jean lassalle ans chez mcdonald's
c'est comme j'essayais de mieux patcher
c'est ridicule mais sinon je suis petit
tu dis c'est ça pour moi je suis juste à
aller maintenant
thilo j'avais juste une conférence à
trois on s'entend que se passait-il pour
pour un show la conférence à trois
regarde c'est comme il n'y a aucune
façon qu'aujourd'hui je mange bien que
je fasse pas au qg aucune solution l'art
comme j'ai rien que peu importe même si
je veux je voyais aller dans l'anecdote
c'est moi ça fait focal de vote sur
trois pour les délibérations
non mais moi j'étais certain que je t'ai
déjà j'étais certain que j'étais déjà
parce que pu d'ailleurs tous ces justes
sur cette anecdote
sinon mais le jeune femme et ses excuses
officielles au monde intego pas ça fait
genre à un hack jeudi kent utd
je n'avais pas de diagnostic j'avais
tennessee
le j'en étais convaincu tenté ph me
connaît depuis toujours été un peu mal
et puis je voulais en faire part tout
mais je pense que j'ai besoin de temps
et agnostiques parce que le chao enfants
ados sa salle est belle je travaillais
pas un côté j'allais à l'école on devait
avoir un corps pareil cette instabilité
ça fait un petit peu moins d élite
le travailleur autonome ok je voyais à
la télé ça fait quand même plusieurs
années que tout est un des plus jeunes
viennent du cégep j'avais encore une
structure de butane versité maintenant
depuis 2000 quand même longtemps gpo
2011 12
c'est comme est ce que ma vie on doit
que ces genres n'importe quoi tu occupes
aucune récursive unions célébrées
aujourd'hui je comprends
[Rires]
non mais aucune routine
chaque journée bbf s'opposer qui est
qu'à chaque journée est tout le temps
différente puisqu'étaient aucune
récurrence piketty travail en plus
vraiment beaucoup il sa fin de la vie
genre normal comme genre répondre à ta
lettre d'or de revenu québec et apporte
en tout genre français décide à faire le
oui ça prenait tout d'abord faire c'est
parce que moi j'ai bien peur moi c'est
comme prix et musique puis à faire la
fin de la vente le soja concept
totalement du temple dans le juif est
toujours resté fermé pis le fait que
jeter les revenus j'ai un problème parce
que dans ma vie j'en sujet pas ma mère
pour m'occuper de mes impôts cher je
suis fini d'un comptable oui un contat
métier genre parce que je la mette la
presse que jamais nos consciences
pas mal non mais finalement je téléphone
toutes les tests neuro psycho mais qui
est vraiment c'est chrismale femme
serait ce comme du jeu at-elle trouvé
salle found et j'ai trouvé ça fait ma
femme je trouve ça nul et même que moi
oui puis jean roy zlb georges képénékian
tesla mettons les fautes ses écrits vers
12h15 rouge ne les footeux 10 dans la
couleur que tu vois l'époque et tu lis
une petite affaire d'âme ou faire des
courses avec des blocs tu que j'allais à
la médication mais pas vraiment parce
que je la prends juste quand c'est
nécessaire
elle met en danger par ma tournée je
l'apprends pas ok merci je mange plus la
suisse appelle vivent ça c'est un spin
égal c'est terrible
cédric était là dessus kate a tourné de
crapauds gênera pas parce qu'il m'en
faut se trouve la fois quand même
complètement gens moi j'ai déjà eu un
passé de drogue
quand j'étais plus jeune puis c'est la
même les mêmes symptômes pas vraiment
comment dit-on corps s'habitue ben c'est
omniprésent
ouais mais au début le c'est terrible
georges la première journée que j'ai
pris ce jeudi sans embauche chez nous
dans mon studio
j'écris ton nom complet une bonne tonnes
an plus tôt
non mais c'était faux que cela genre ces
foules
ces malades mais est ce qui m'attend
pour le mcs personne peut avoir cette
réponse là mais excuse je me demande si
ça mais si mettons pour toi tu t'étais
focus a pas de sens pim et ont le
sentiment qu tôt c'est ce que quelqu'un
qui épate et des eaux est tout le temps
mais ton dépresseurs là dedans ça agit
un peu comme ça il y en a qui ont pas le
diagnostic était aussi je me trompe pas
pis ils vont avoir une prescription de
vivans m'avance mais pas sur ce que je
dis mais
j'ai aucune idée moi je sais juste que
leur ont commencé avec 20 mg pas sa
trentième année cette route et vous ça
fait l'effet inverse rock et encore
moins efficace que ce qu'elles étaient
avant parce que c'est rôle d'information
au fond c'est ce qu'ils m'ont expliqué
c'est que ces déconnecte une correction
est exactement les miennes sont il y en
a qui coupent fac ça fait juste les
tenir ensemble ça se voit justement ça
se voit à l'écran tu peux voir ses
collections le petit ali
mais le piège titanic mais c'est
beaucoup mais je retourne à votre hôtel
après tu as dis moi ce que tu as de l'ap
des tests puis des adultes ainsi
qu'acheter quitter a dit moi je peux pas
te donner des tapes a sauté juste je
travaille trop puis j'entends aucune
stock une régularité donc une routine à
cause de ton travail tu envie que des
musiciens peut-être ta part tu y vas
qu'il faudrait juste mais comme tu
fasses attention à ce titre wet ben
correct avec dans le fond ce que je
pense que tu es un gros problème c'est
juste qu'il est dans le fond il faut
juste que je change de trop défendre
puis avons une routine un petit peu par
tapie jaurès à la routine le lagutin ce
genre de truc car tu es jeune tu te dire
moi jamais je vais ouvrir une routine
parce que je parle pour une petite plate
comme les parents sachent quand j'écoute
les petites émissions fille couchée dans
le salon mais là on la routine c'est
genre la clé pour accomplir quoi que ce
soit parce que la régularité sur le long
terme dit c'était qu'il répond à un
livre si un après midi c'est la goutine
ces gens-là constante à chaque jour
quelque chose de connu maurice tu vois
vraiment comme rouler ils m'ont chopé
commun qu'ils font là parce que j'y
arriverai jamais assumé il y en a qui
disent qu'il faut qu'ils écrivent 30
minutes d'humour par jour que ce soit
bon ou mauvais on s'assoit tchéquie josé
houde jarry écrit trois heures chaque
matin se lève et qui trois ans après ces
faits sa journée
défait par son après midi dans son salon
que de la musique eu beau divin messie
crise en trois heures le matin c'est
comme il faut mais c'est bon c'est bon
oui effectivement mettez les à clermont
dion le lait clairement dit dans la
façon dr e fête intime et la faiblesse
vient de certains romans mais c'est
parce que l entrée la baby baby baby
si j'étais un imprévu avec mais en
entrevue ce thème table ronde à radio
canada qu'elle puis rosalie bonenfant
dit je t'aime tellement impressionné
agen tellement aucune preuve son premier
plongeon rodrigues a fait toute sa vie
[Rires]
son chapeau est en train d'écrire un
roman mais t elle ces gamines ce pas de
casser qui disait à dix mois des
tamarins terreur à chaque joueur j'écris
chaque jour puisqu'on fait accompli les
enfants thé dessus ce que tu écris en ce
moment été tué et deux cousines de
composition beaucoup de textes écrits
pour le premier don qui n'ont pas été
tous pris par le premier album
facilement rester j'ai écrit quelques
trucs way pendant l'année les deux ans
sa deuxième mon album est sorti puis le
on a à peu près toutes les chansons pour
le deuxième album fait que je suis
vraiment content très juste à trouver
tes mcl c'est plus mates qui rentrent en
compte pour la musique y tourner mais
ouais ça va vraiment vite sans sembler
le premier qu'est ce que maintenant je
l'écouté c'est quoi et c'est non mais
maintenant le premier album j'étais avec
un réalisateur filme at&t correa
s'attend à que sérieuse le premier
réseau temps je le respecte énormément
et a fait du bon travail
c'est juste que moi je savais pas ce que
je voulais lui y est allé avec tisser
ils lancèrent à hauteur de marge ou
pitié comme c'était moins comme mon bac
fax j'écoute mon album je l'aimais jeu
comme sans plus c'est comme au début je
tripe aimé le jeu d'aller ailleurs
l'anchois on a tout ruiné empêchant son
nom m'a tout les signaux radio ces
maquisards taper pour que ce soit
vraiment radiophonique fac
le stage stores sont que je vais me
reconnais que dans le jeu capable de
massifs dirhams at mes débuts
c'est comme moi je connais rien je fais
des cinq mâts bouge
la vraie celui il fera sec et des
habitants pour tous les allées du site
les bridges cache pas s'allier à loyer
la page
je me rappelle quand avait sorti quand
tu as sorti un clip
le clip c'est m il y avait plein de
trucs démoli autour de toi le cette
école soit exactement ce qu'attend sorti
ses clips
il ya vu un genre de ta vu un genre de
bâclage des fans de déco way qui était
là depuis le début
qui disait comme sensiblement corrigez
moi si je me trompe ce n'est ce pas toi
ça c'est trop produits salés fake c'est
un backlash ses com - sur 1000
commentaires si on a un méchant c'est le
savez pas été si gros mois si ça m'avait
atteint à ce point là bon ok tout ce
temps rappelle parce que moi j'en ai
reparlé exact mais j'avais vu j'avais vu
les commentaires en dessous de la vidéo
quelques commentaires la plupart c'était
positif évidemment tout sûrement raison
mais après ce que j'avais vu toi qu'ils
avaient admis qu'une chaude défendre la
gare ce qu'ils avaient raison ah ouais
ouais c'est vraiment beaucoup de pain au
début puis je me rappelle j'ai pleins ça
m'avait tellement de peine sa première
fois moi je vais les garder sur internet
le blind
j'en ai pour 1 puis quand j'en ai j'ai
comme un art mais avec des départs mais
quand j'avais vu ce que l'on attendait
ça très sympa
c'est trop liche épi jetais comme ça par
la fois que je mettais comme défendu en
disant que c'est normal d'évoluer blanc
puis je les écoute ce que plus
aujourd'hui ça me ressemble pas fait
assez souvent c'est ce qui arrive quand
je le sais parce que ça m'est arrivé
aussi deux amis recevant un commentaire
qui est négatif puis phare genre
tabarnak celui des masses solaires
résonne plus parce que au fond de moi je
le sais ouais métier puis elle c'est pas
la faute de personne je veux dit la
réalisatrice de script lui je la donne
change georges en chasserait mon ami
dans vie lorsqu'on prend comme toute
l'équipe était super fin puis c'est
vraiment l'équipe était super film voilà
c'est vraiment un ton monte ma moyon
dieye on voit on l'essaie on va ailleurs
on le sait on parce que moi c'est
toujours moi qui réalise puisse toujours
moi qui fais le montage ses fans oui je
suis d'accord avec ma prof de faire on
doit aller ailleurs on doit mettre une
qualité pour que les grands médias ou le
grand public plus plus mainstream façon
de goûter mais mettons des petits bouts
de toile ça a été filmé avec une canne
7x puis ça a été monté par mois les
ralentis il cache un peu c'est comme
faire oui les crimes jean 6 millions de
visionnements ce texte le parce que les
gens ils se reconnaissent là dedans
c'est pas trop loin de tripy sais pas si
c'est moi c'est 100 % - si tu regardes
les sas de notre belle démence il ya
plus de vue sur la version de guitare
voix que j'avais fait être comme 2.5
millions de visionnements que sur ses
clips le full budget bis c'est plate
mais ça arrive c'est puis je peux pas
considérer ça comme un bad move lustin
suprême crible c'est juste que ça me
ressemble pas c'est tout mais il ya une
leçon très déçus parce qu'on pense que
c'est bon parce que je suis comme deux
fois que à plat
ce qui est super tir il introduit c'est
bon je voyais pas comment permettait non
mais la leçon à tirer de tout cela c'est
que pas parce que tu peux y est pour
quelque chose
on pense que tu vois plus grosse pas
parce que tu vois plus ciblé ce que ça
va plus toucher le monde va venir avec
la montée puis justement petits bouts de
toi on le voit là que c'est possible de
bien c'est pas tout mais il ya de quoi
qui est une honnêteté là dedans à une
humilité la da qui touche à monter oui
si ce je pense qu'ils créent qui ont une
armée de coco comme se sait que ils sont
proches de toi c'est vraiment la
proximité du web
kiev est seul c'est plus fort que tout
métier comme je dis ce pas une erreur je
l'essayé ouais les clips gens l'aiment
je le regarde je laime c'est un beau
clip mais c'est très très riche et sont
très loin de moins moche et que c'est
quelque chose que je suis ces policiers
[Rires]
c'est c'est vraiment un homme mais je
pensais pas que tu as les cas jamais je
pensais pas que je pensais pas que ça
allait arriver peut-être allez dire ça
se fait la queue effectivement ce n'est
pas tout non mais c'est parce que je
n'ai pas entendu parler de ce tour le
temps n'apporte pas non j'avais fait je
mettais défendu cette semaine la
pression mon équipe m'a dit arrête et
excusé quelques entités excuses c'est de
dire aux gens que tu as tort à 8 ans
c'est pas une mauvaise décision c'est ça
que j'ai nous sommes obligés j'en ai pas
parlé mais j'ai fait un sale germé en
moi c'est je me suis posé les bonnes
questions je les réécoute et réécouter
puis je me suis dit chris les
commentaires sont vraiment venu me
chercher c'est parce que ils ont raison
c'est aussi simple que ça je faisais
quand tu disputes avec quelqu'un puis il
ya quelque chose qui ressort que le
sablais
c'est vrai tu étais probablement
l'exemple le meilleur exemple en fait
des médias alternatifs des médias
traditionnels traditionnels se rejoint
je pense qu'il ya personne qui a réussi
à connecter les deux comme tu le fais
comme de gagner la chanson de l'année à
l'adisq on s'entend c'est comme le gala
d'égal musicale ce c'est un des prix
sinon le prix le plus convoité
ouais c'est bien c'est pas que c'est
plus convoités c'est juste parce qu'il
ya le public
je suis mis fin quand le public
exact fait que toi tu es comme consacré
là mais avec le avec tout le back in
d'aimer dieu médias sociaux en fait
puis c'est la première fois que ça
arrive mais ces coûts réalisées en fait
à moins que à moins que quelqu'un dise
d'un commentaire ticket quinquis arriver
avant mais je pense pas maintenant j'ai
eu qu'à se couchant qui est venu chez
nous veulent deux semaines puis c'est ça
qui m'a dit m
c'est fou a dit est la première personne
qui dit exactement jean jé comme sortent
pas sorti du web mais jean est allé
chercher je connaissais tu reconnais que
les insectes et les deux oui parce que
tu restes tu restes sur le web aussi
parce que même après l'adisq la praille
c'est tout y allions tout fait des
articles genre une nouvelle façon de ne
pas de voter soyons ici me rappelle pas
du titre exact mais si c'est le tract
avait utilisé les soirées pops ou pas -
exactement je sais pas si c'était gentil
ou si ça se voulait un peu sarcastique
mais comme c'est vrai que j'ai réussi à
avoir le prix parfois importe peu
importe c'est qu'il décrit comme ça
c'est la réalité
le monde qui te suivent
il sourit parce que tu aimes pivote
portois pis si tu leur as fait une façon
facile d'aller voter pour toi c'est sûr
qu'ils vont voter pour toi la 4g
marc dupré qui m'ont écrit la semaine où
ça avait été annoncé qu'elle on pouvait
voter puis il m'avait dit en tout cas
moi mon vois tu vois pour ta chance il a
mené la même catégorie
il m'a répondu je mens à crissey ta
chanson la chasse aux oies
c'est un p'tit quinquin car mon nom est
ressorti le cai a dit roxanne même pas
dit roxanne bruno jeanbart la voix de
richard y avait de la joie
ouais y'a dit roxanne était content puis
- j je me suis juste écroulé smash isles
c'est mon attachée de presse après kim
wan tout son regard des problèmes où
j'ai vraiment eu un don je regarde en
tant que j'ai fais pas ci si j'entendais
cilip ma blonde mais il m'a dit tu
comprends pas la salle s'était pas
protocolaire on se lève on applaudit le
monde un peu tout le monde il est gentil
même qu'il est trop belle comme ça c'est
du public ouais ça criait mongole même
quand je faisais mes remerciements à
télé on l'entend pole parce que le son
qui tous les jeudis s'arrange pour qu'on
entende quel artiste dit lemay litres au
balcon maniche veux saluer les gens tout
gêné vazquez c'est la folie furieuse
enroulé way ceci dit mettons le monde
sur youtube il ya tellement d'inconnues
que tu choisis lequel tu veux écouter
exactement 4 90 on shoppe écoutant radio
en cause un con comme à la télé on
t'impose de voir quelque chose faite
le public c'est sûr que si ton choisi
toi parce qu'il y avait tellement de
choix
moi je veux dire que tu vois sur youtube
le jeu peut choisir ce que je veux je
peux choisir en anglais je peux choisir
des français de france choisir n'importe
qui de contenus que je consomme fake
c'est sûr que je suis plus attaché au
monde que je décide d'écouter within au
visionnement sont encore là je vais pas
bâché l'élément traditionnel c'est juste
que nos visionnement sont tellement plus
représentatif dans le sens où quand j'ai
une vidéo qui ont un million de vues
c'est un million personnes qui m'ont
choisi parce qu'ici c'est une
suggestion qui popent après en vidéo qui
s'attendent pas de risque et le
visionnement il ya embarque paul pour
t'écouter je pense deux minutes les gens
où la moitié de la vidéo pour ça qu'on
s'est passablement tout cas pas comme
facebook seconde où ça bouge à 50
secondes sur youtube
colton coûté exactement ses fans au
visionnement sont beaucoup plus
représentatif des gens qui avaient envie
de regarder qu'un talk show qui qui qui
est en avance mathon sont les
visionnements le peut-être pas de mets
ton de tout le monde en parle mais il ya
bien eu ce n'est pas quelque chose que
les lits de ces postes radios pirates et
les ja seulement nous écoutent pas s'est
il aussi le territoire radio la radio
quand même personne font juste mettre la
radio puis georges descendent des
volumes outils et conduit sans porter
attention au sens choisir qu'est-ce qui
écoute juste parce que ils y ont démarré
le moteur s'est joué à ce moment c'est
un conte drôle parce que moi aussi je
pense et j'avais cette mentalité lieu
avant que la radio c'était comme mme
aubry mais depuis que jean je vaux à la
radio faire des entrevues ou méchants
sont pas ceux que je connais les
animateurs je parle avec eux si fou on y
serait supprimé la radio si c'est encore
très très écouté il faisait pas juste
avec lui les stats des cours juste avec
les gens qui t'aiment l'interaction est
très sûrement
c'est vrai tu dis monde qui criait je
trois campagnes et le à l'adisq l'été
jane harman et mais enfin ça m'a fait
penser que mon mari me nommer aussi
catégorique c'est comme ça qu'ils y
mettent à crier puis se retournait pas
dire merci au monté pis il ya vraiment
de quoi était vraiment quoi dans le
public était cela revient à sauter les
prix ou les laiteries pitou merci d'un
critique où je même le même les pertes
c'est même là
le respecté ou être apprécié par ses
parts tout ça c'est le fun mais c'est le
public qui fait la différence en bout de
loin c'est ce public qui va faire qu'il
faut de volonté salle qui est très
capable de vives de guinée 4 4 2 c'est
moi cette année je fais comme tu as
maintenant que j'ai pas été invité et
maintenant au gala de la socan et
j'avais été invité mais si j'avais
pointé invité les jeux les croiser la
fiba a jamais répondu à l'invitation
grange à lavelanet manque que sérieux tu
es vraiment triste de ne pas avoir été
invitée l'objet comme sa maman je passe
le manie pour connaissance de matty m'a
dit qu'est ce tu es mieux tant mieux
avant jean quasiment sans chaussettes
année quasiment tout soldat ou un
trophée de la saga mais là ce cas toute
façon c'est se poser la question c'est y
répondre
ce cas c'est pas intimement liées
justement au succès populaire
ce qu'est ce que je sais pas si à sa 15e
les droits d'auteur et où je pense que
plus moi mais je pense que plus tard on
joue à la radio ce plus tourrenc trophée
de la saccade waimes en même temps gigan
une chanson de l'année
logique c'est que la haye après je m'en
fous je n'ai même pas y aller pour notre
fille j'ai même pas être nominée vous
êtes invités - valeo parts et après elle
s est imposée distance par m
mes parents j'ai invité six mois j'en
appelle à bienne et répété qu'elle
convainc mais j'ai oublié des avertis
aux parts et après les photos avec les
artistes
bof yorkais barnak en exil notre nom et
marie-mai pts 10 mon papy mouettes
on peut quitter le mans nice et ceux qui
savent vraiment pas ma tasse a amassé
deux faces mec babar monbailly fief à
qui il ya des photos et ginette reno
m'arrive est double c'est fort king
drôle parce que mon père montre la photo
de ma midi comme la photo est belle mais
accuse les cavs qui n'y a eu en arias 1
go de mémoire je le câble c'est son job
en effet aux abeilles ainsi qu un quasi
coma
c'est bon c'est bon si grosse daube est
un peu chaude highway me sorti par
exemple des contingents un petit mes
parents j'ai invité le plus vieux à ma
blonde et gable son fils avec sa blonde
trip est il un pion je vais mouiller
tête à manseau j'allais perdre que j'ai
dit je ne paye un trip gimont limoges
engager un gardien sa chance comme ça
devient même un caniveau wesh comme ça
fait vraiment big shot animaux oui
c'était jure comme un prix de
consolation l'alimenter mais je voulais
pas que personne c'est barack on dirait
que tout le monde puisse boire s'être
vraiment estimé facto plus mon beauf est
elle aussi vient d'avoir 19 ans il avait
18 ans je voulais vraiment qui triplent
qui pensent que c'est seulement ça a
marché
vous mélangez de la limo mais ils m'ont
pas fait attendre et il le lendemain tu
es comme suit ce fait il ya été dredd
comme une basse et incertain du parti
aux salles lactique et le vin c'est le
vin c'est pas par les gens accusant mme
nadeau avec marie-mai lui était comme
capoter le congrès parce que c'est parti
là c'est débile moi j'avais
avec mâts blancs dont on faisait goûter
en tester nos pleurs d'enfants enfin un
des plats surgelés en soit nice est vrai
félicitations c'est vraiment merci
fausse route
ouais j'aurais pu ramener mais oui je me
sens plus mal on est vraiment est rendue
comme 100% vj votant oui j'ai voté oui
au fait qu'on est allé faire tester nos
produits dans le fond à l'after-party
des gémeaux puis ma soeur céline donné
un coup de main c'est ma soeur a dit
leur peut acheter si je vois des
célébrités joie aussi de garder mon
calme des médias n'avaient qu'à me
justin comme que si je vois ça se peut
que je perds mes moyens qui c'est claude
legault tu sais j'avais géré durant
l'été qui skie avec le si claude legault
vient écouter nos clubs s'ils sont un
peu naïve mal s'il vient kitano petit
j'y parle d'elle c'est qu'elle est
tellement on est là mais moi je tenterai
de faire quelque chose ne tourner le
claude legault et leurs antennes de
tchéquie qu'est ce qu'on fait là on est
comme des tortellinis haut à fos viande
petits enfants l'envié m'a dit c'est toi
smaïl à sa religion et romano mason à
fond moi je sers vite ma soeur a
présenté les plus le cas je me tourne
il est comme la plus in check mars en
commandant une explication m'a soral à
chuke complètement le genre y'a rien qui
sort le mode voix seule je me rappelle à
m'avait dit que si avoir toutes les
gauches allait perdre ses moyens à voix
claude legault et ses paroles la partie
fait quelqu'un grâce à présenter truc
mais le monde s'arrache la face dans ces
affaires les oui c'est ça que j'ai des
photos sinon non lui lui était pas chaud
lui était pas chômé il y en a qui sont
le vrai c'est ça petit les photos les
gens qui sont le riz banane on ne m'a
pas vraiment ce fait demandé des photos
que je t'ai comment qu'il marie mai est
il a des choses à faire ici mais mais
c'est s'appuie
[Musique]
c'est comme une soirée dans l'année où
est-ce qu'on est utile parce que comme
tout le monde dit si la personne qui
doit se soucier de son image non c'est
ça exactement où le parti en béton on
s'est tellement ça me fait tellement
rire parce qu'il ya beaucoup d'artistes
moutons qui m'ont parlé là ça fait trois
ans que je vois première année aucune
domination personnes savez je t'écris
deuxième année nomination perdu
troisième année j'ai un fils soit clos
il ya eu vraiment une espèce de monter
des qui viennent par l'ue - surtout le
smitom petite affaire le 2 févr
j'arrive pas vraiment franck semblant
ces factions s'est pas vu le gars que je
vous dise oui le mec comme il faut on
était un peu propres abris étaient
vraiment les gens les gens sont ils trop
gentille comme c'est normal parce que
même moi je vois une trop gentille mais
comme ge com mais il y en a plein qui me
parlait des joueurs tels années passées
en aplomb et qui me parlait des jeux
flash je t'aime c'est comme les déos en
avance et se moucher loin de personnes
de 10 watts en mon band
je veux que ce soit mon bain et jusqu'à
la fin parce que c'est trop facile après
oman voici une petite liste à guiglo man
parce qu'elle allait aller choper c'est
quoi si la personne est là pour ton nom
catherine s'amuser ou pour la paix si je
veux passer pour ce que je veux les
personnes qui m'entourent présentement
c'est les personnes qui ont cru au
projet c'est ce projet était fort qu'à
la fin c'est faux faux faux attribué
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup d'importance
aux gens qu'ils font quand ces papillons
exactement ce mets ton école d'eton
qu'elle en a fait un challenge bleu je
sais pas combien de temps ils te
commencé ici comme un tapis le début
juillet début juillet waits et puis on a
fait juste un gars avec qui qui qui peut
venir me donne un coup de main une kelly
a fait crissement des podcasts
gratuitement avant qu'on fasse lots
nicole t on a besoin de quelqu'un plus
sérieusement c'est toi sion relance même
pas de nom mais c'est sûr que c'est toi
dans le temps ouais c'est sûr lipides
nicole non plus permanent et kenzo on
s'est mis à avoir plusieurs semaines on
sait bien pu faire
argent avec les sponsors avec les view
enfants nettement
parlons-en justement tu viens de lancer
un podcast oui oui oui avec krikri web
pour dirait l'autre valencien podcast
sur sa chaîne youtube - ça s'appelle en
parle pour parler c'est vraiment avant
je consommais pas tant de podcasts je
suis venu chez alice sûr cela de what
the fuck yeah je suis venu sur le vote
chaalis au lendemain c'est là que j'ai
vraiment eu un espèce de décrire des
crises et nice paris si nous parler du
monde s'aime et on le sait sur quel est
le soit autant que j'aime parce que
c'est le chuck world mais dans une
conversation - james oui parce que on
apprend des trucs
j'en sais qu'avant mais ont des
anecdotes drôles on a tout le monde
apprend des trucs tu me dis qu'ils vont
le faire et je vois pas bien mon début
par ce qui équivaut mais oui c'était
plus sauter comme tout le monde c'est
fou c'est que j'ai même fait ait jamais
eu autant de nice mon podcast écrivait
moqueries au milieu du monde mais je
vois pas nommé personne mais m'ont
vraiment connu tu mon appli qui m'ont
écrit tu devrais vous j'aimerais voir
ton podcast comme et malignes
c'est que je vois pas y aller avec qui
qui est le plus connu qui est le moins
connu entier je veux des gens pas connu
pendant toutes j'arrête pas dormi le
même exemple autant mon sens le même
s'appelle arnaud c'est legault le plus
effacé au monde et qui jouit lui est un
hit à l'école à l'université ils doivent
par les trans patience et achemine fa
cup et lui c'est ça il veut devenir
psychiatre psychologue
puis tout qu'est-ce qui me raconte tout
en gardant l'anonymat
aujourd'hui raconte jamais rien de
précis mais c'est tellement il m'apprend
tellement gens les discussions de loges
les discussions de chambres d'hôtels
sont tellement intéressante avec arnaud
j'existe rettig est menée par le podcast
si je me suis dis pas je sers non dans
la vie que des enfants disent qu'ils
jugent centre rosa bonne et même pas
d'instagram d'enfants facile et je me
suis dit je peux me fier aux nombres
d'abonnés je me fie à quel point tu est
intéressant et pertinent quand tu parles
je pas non plus que ce soit rogers d'une
crise d'accor intelligemment
tabarnak ici que ses pensées là où j'ai
perdu le sens ouest-est
mais que fait exactement je veux pas que
ce soit un concours de popularité bi
poin c'est quand je demande aux gens dit
moi qui vous aimeriez voir c'est ce que
c'est des gens populaires qui m'écrivent
parce qu'ils connaissent pas les genres
populaires et même en mettant la semaine
prochaine j'ai une de mes amies
d'enfance qui investit passé de
consommation des bilans elle a fait
l'école y est noté comme allopass a
travaillé aujourd'hui ça fait deux trois
ans je pense qu est abstinent tu sais
que je veux qu'à vienne me parler de
tout de ckoi touché le fond puis comment
te fait pour monter parce que clairement
il ya des gens sur internet qu'ils
vivent sur ces faits qui savent à des
trucs que les gens m'ont vraiment plus
solide que quand on parle de la disent
qu'ils peuvent parler quand on parle des
gemmes où les gens ils peuvent pas fort
en moi aussi quand celle où j'ai monté
comme taxer ce soir des discussions que
je m'en fais avec mcchrystal mais
faudrait avant tout le monde peut
maintenant 6 mai mais c'est bon de farce
c'est une zone d'attenté quand même pas
mal de d'avenue de trucs potentiellement
faisable avec le podcast on le fait
aussi avec des eti de voir qu'est ce
qu'est ce qu'on peut faire mais c'est
sûr que ça prend une balance d'un
surtout si tu fais un peu casse basé sur
l'invité sur une conversion que les
décès sur ça prend une balance avec la
notoriété des invités parce que
l'algorithme est trop chiant mais moi ce
qui m'a aidé c'est que machin c'est
parce que je me suis dit je pars 100
gagne pas de gaspé je me suis dit non
parce que si je fais ça vous un peu hâte
de voir tout le temps avoir exactement
puis au début je l'aï dit au monde c'est
moi je l'aimais même pas sûr balade
hôpitaux autres parce que bien sûr
youtube à ses instincts podcast qui se
regarde beaucoup plus qui s'écoute parce
que j'ai comme dévié
les règles du pos de gas dans ce sens
exactement c'est au début je crois qu'il
faut que ce soit un plan séquence faut
que ce soit tant pis dati depuis à part
ça je me suis dit faut tu vas tu es
comme moi ce qui fait ma marque de
commerce sur youtube c'est les images
stupide que j incorpore où les effets
sonores où chaque mois des fois je sens
aussi faisons c'est sans filtre moyens
on en est ce parce que j'ai quand emma
prod2 toujours comme oublie pas qu une
carrière qui implique beaucoup d'êtres
humains en ce moment les communes
d'eysines estime enfin que je peux pas
vraiment faire et dire tout ce que je
veux non parce que je me sens soja mais
j'ai déjà dit ça maintenant être vu
c'est que peu importe le propos où je
veux aller je voyais aller je dois juste
trouver l'angle le moins de lecture est
juste pour dire qu'ils lui qui te nuire
est anxieux que ce pourrait faire aux
yeux en 2019 n'importe quoi bien que je
me dis tantôt j tu as fait de mieux dans
le match comme un stade ils m'ont grosse
tête haute je veux pas qu'il y ait des
gens qui sentent insultés parce que j'ai
dit je veux pas devenir gros s'était
passé mon point c'était pour la santé
mais j'ai utilisé le mot grosse package
paranoid park a déjà blessé mais se sait
moi c'est dans ma personnalité c'est
même par roxane bruno la personne connue
c'est comme moi j'aime pas se blesser
les gens cette fac
le chercheur trois gaules avec ce moment
mais ça va passer
fa oui des trucs a maintenant des
invités qui vont emmener qui vont aller
sur des terrains que moi j'irais pas te
met en boîte de franck est un personnage
à ses colosses mais d'éviter que nous on
dirait pas exactement un bon nécessaire
de s'inscrire
moi je l'avertissement mon public sur
youtube ces 7 à 77 fac comme clairement
ils vont à des coupures si on est allé
sur le terrain que et en plus avec
internet ce qui est magique c'est qu'on
peut prendre deux secondes d'un clip
l'enlever le maître sans le contexte et
c'est terminé pour toi c'est ben oui
gbagbo et des bougies enlevé pour
produire du nécessairement justement
avoir évoqué ce que je veux pour servir
de ma chaise s'il ya quelque chose qui
l'entachent il peut sans tache et que
tant qu'il veut mais moi je peux
lantages et puis moi aussi j'ai pas
envie de me faire couler parce qu'en
même temps il dit quelque chose sur les
j'adhère pas du tout ça les gens ne
peuvent pas comprendre ce que je pense
je ne peuvent pas faire la lingerie sur
son podcast baladeur à tout ce qu'ils
disent pas vrai ces facs moi il ya des
bouts que je vais enlever ou même des
fois j'ai comme un running gag aux
censeurs
changement de bombes vrombissement bible
sur ce que je dis pas c'est un projet
secret qui est pas encore sorti ou pas
de romain est venu on a parlé d'une
conversation qu'ont eue avec le band
dans une chambre d'hôtel puis clairement
monde était veux pas qu'on répète ce qui
est dit fact the le même et ce qui est
drôle c'est que les gens ils savent sont
comme bastian encore censuré de quoi il
parle et on sera jamais faite moi si je
m'amuse avec ce ne sont pas blessés pour
posh acquis pour pas non plus connu est
la personne qui ne cède pas de casse
c'est une bonne façon de voir ce nom
qu'on avait on monte on faisait des des
extraits de par cas si on arrive à temps
avec toi sur quatre ne parlait de
l'anxiété
quand tu étais allé et j'ai tellement
déçu vous amical risquer menem est un
droit quand même des meubles à pied
après ça on sentait que mal quand tu
vois c'était vraiment pas un exemple qui
était ce qu'était clic beit sahour et
qu'ils ont un dossier qui mettait même
si c'est comme 320000 visionnement sur
ce clip ne suis pas comme ça écouter la
conversation complet pour recevoir
l'information que quand elles arrivent
pièces que vous sentiez que ça avait un
impact sur à qui ils vont écouter ce qui
l'est plus donc ils vont aller voir les
crises au complet ou c'est vraiment qu
yves jung su et sophistiquée l'équipe de
james ellison à dos a relaté rythme
dirigé du monde mais des fois avec les
pistons remarqué aussi c'est que des
fois les réactions étaient moins
positive outils ou llm ou steam et on a
fait un clip qui avec les codes des
booms film ou qu'on parlait que l'homme
macworld avait comme accusés qui avaient
volé le concept the legends est papa
pour les troupes de papables le savent
at ridgemont des cds valeur pigeon y
avait foule et les clips avait plus de
10 l'an ii le monde qu'il est sur les
clics biker longue cherche de quad a pas
aimé est ce qu'elle est c'est un bout de
cassation hors contexte peu tout les
reste au total open raison précise
moi je fais des extraits mais c'est pas
petit foc ligue b c'est vraiment juste
je mets sur instagram 6 50 secondes de
discussion pour que les gens aient envie
d'aller voir ce qu'on fait parce que
c'est ça de jouer la game
mais les cliques bt partout maintenant
bon allez je te mets quoi de phoques
kiev le mahb l'on n'ait été à l'avant
boer 40 ans donc elle elle est une
grande consommatrice de télévision
traditionnelle puis mais mettons à leur
écoute sur les plates formes ici tout
peut arriver et tout puis c'est tout
l'art bleu où je sais pas quelles
émissions que je suis vraiment bonne
public cible à l' écoute ce que je
l'écouterai pourrait favoriser le
principe de l'émission est un clic bect
les 50 premières secondes de l'émission
et comme il parle mort et blanc mais il
comme un bleu t1 purge pour te montrer
que ça va arriver dans l'émission
mexique pas tout de suite sa coupe
toujours à steam
qu'est ce qui va arriver c'est que ma
magnifique berçait un bébé ipte a
l'impression qu'ils avaient fini par le
secouer parce qu'à part impatience parce
qu'il pleure puis finalement cette
bouteille harry voir la fin de
l'émission pour te garder en haleine
tout le long mais finale couchepin tout
est beau s'il y arrive jamais rien ces
facs
c'est vraiment un principe clic b mais
dans la télé traditionnelle on est rendu
là passion de jeanne a presque jamais ce
cas si jamais jamais jamais jamais il un
fouet même même dernièrement et crds le
geek comme l'était le réseau des sports
depuis packing longtemps et c'est qui
qui qui a excédé nouvelles de sport
c'est plus l'heure sur facebook
maintenant place d'avoir mettons claude
julien retranche
charles hudon mettant le sait vous ne
croirez pas qu'est ce que claude julien
fait à charles hudon blessés comme je
veux savoir c'est quoi la nouvelle je
veux pas être obligé cliquez sur voter
ce type d'article c'est quoi 14
paragraphe après mais en même temps
toute notre génération commence à
rentrer en poste c'est exact c'est
l'information avec qu'elle avait reçus
et roseline filion le web ac le
troisième paquet 2e 3e puis je te martek
rds exactement de mama fois que c'était
l'émission de kevin raphaël t il
vous ne croirez jamais ce qu'il faut
c'est une fille ont avoué qu'ils vendent
raphaël fnac c'est quoi c'est quoi
quelques vidéos
j'ai vraiment pas des auteurs via l'avs
gens à l'avouer qu avant de plonger à
l'écouté d'or du daddy yankee dans ses
écouteurs
c'était ça le vous ne croirez jamais
fait avant par un crime était quelque
chose vous ne croirez jamais seul
j'aurai alors je le croise quelques
têtes raides à 10 ans qui puis je te
croise alors tiana acheter quoi ça ça
semble osé se sentent d'être une
personne de confiance à à s'y croirait
jamais mais ouais c'est sympa que le
podcast c'est juste contente mais en
même temps c'est que c'est vraiment
projet kunst rien ça me sort de ma zone
de confort justement parce que les
discussions là je commence à aimer ton
vous vous êtes 2,6 en silence
il y en a un sur six est comme moi ici à
dakar n'a pas eu je contente mais qui
sait 14 sur kate
oui bien fait tout à cliff à tout abonné
du terrain cette fois posé un pénis dans
la formation
non je ne dis pas que j'arrive il
n'aurait plein garde jean hamdi ou à
l'iran dans le processus puis à ce
bientôt j'aurai plus de testostérone
pantoute est blanche comme pourquoi pas
quand même pas ce que j'aurais pu 2
elle a besoin de paix n'était alors plus
le système qui donne cet aspect mais moi
et c'est tellement de femmes ce que je
pense que c'est le conservions faire
l'attraction pourront pas que je fais tu
aurais pu d'utérus c'est tout puis elle
à margaux il ya vraiment un délai les
deux ans regarde l'asie dans cette
affaire est que m'a dit reste le haut
par ari puis après ça j'essaie de
rattraper à chaud en âmes était
tellement pour moi tellement mais je
prends les sultans dans tellement de
femmes parce que c'est une femme quand
lé strict je suis bourgoin - javier
difficilement rouge en vie roger s'en
tenir chaud honnêtement la tête à la
montée simon j'étais tellement gêné mais
après tu es comme pauvres est assez fort
qingdao la limite c'est juste qu'ils me
colle mais si vous ce serait un pas de
casque des estives bonne réaction
oui romain fait que j'ai un ami qui fait
la transition inverse de est il devenu
un homme amnesty bongo la porte au
dessus de gens toutes les filles trip de
succès mais ça va être drôle de joie
l'invisibilité travail de mon par livrer
à mal jean lui sa transition est ternie
je suis ronde avait tablé combat
aujourd'hui j'attends paris mais c'est
othman parce qu'il ya tellement de kits
guy me suis peut-être ça va juste
répondre à toutes leurs questions sans
aucun doute les défis qu'ils viennent
des goules soit ça paraît fou comme il y
en a que ça paraît mais honnêtement lui
que j'invite le tu peux pas savoir lui
sont grosses vagues en ce moment c'est
de le dire je t'aime et on a qui voient
mais c'est comme moi 20 c'est comme
quand l'inde avance par respect pour la
financer il y en a qui ont pas besoin de
l'accord lille ça paraît qu'ils aient
une transition mettant la bêtise parce
que mettons des défis avec des traits
masculins et en a mais mais pas tant que
ça parce que des gens avec des traits
féminins se met ton jared leto t il ya
des traits super fins d'être est
vraiment féminin be the dallas buyers
club qui quitte une transe en fait il ça
paraît sensé vraiment il ya des traits
vraiment féminin mais je pense que je
parle je sais pas de quoi je parle parce
que je lis pas fait mais je pense que de
devenir de passé d'homme à femmes ça
doit être un processus bout
ou plus compliquée qu'elle inverse
dansant dans le sens où il ya beaucoup
de matches kate moto est elle assez fou
de respecter à la pâte chirurgie ses
confrères il ya des hommes qui vont
faire lit mais là pas la pomme d'adam
halimi leurs cordes vocales qui vont se
répéter mais qui vont se faire mon choix
mais aussi tous ses pôles si c'est pas
sympa pauvre et moi c'est une fuite
d'eau rôle d'invitée on engage tous
quelque chose
puis tout est féminin basket août gens
ayant un acte va rencontrer puis il ya
quand même le rôle tu te parle un peu
mon corps morts cinq un bagage piqué
elle c'est fou le genci plus une femme
qui est une femme très mal mais parlant
de très fins toute cette belle femme
mais c'est les yeux
c'est vrai que j'ai des traits fins
qu'un camp mettons je me range je les
trouvais enfants
[Musique]
pour l'instant ça vole pas pour
l'instant même mon corps c'est mon corps
quand je me regarde je vois pas quelque
chose de sympa les trois noms noms
exacts qui s'en vient c'est ton pas 4 3
2 je vois aussi j'ai comme diderot
montage d'avant ok tu me réponds trop
tard du big bang et venger et christine
qui est sorti je vois cast cast jean
stein est bon pas de casquette bouchard
louise iphone mais mon pied a besoin de
grosses débile on fait des vidéos
ensemble ils on est vraiment les plus
comme dans les conversations qui se
tienne je suis vraiment fier de nous
judum nomades romain un bel et bien la
souffrance à g à qui je parle je me
demandais c'était bel et bien à 100 avec
mon guitariste je savais déjà tous et
6-4 à bazas et maccione qui a eu un
groupe assez de consommation gsm le clan
qui est une fille qui fait beaucoup de
radios
l'animatrice radio aura froid bien
cloutier kiev marquis de kaboul le snow
facebook encore parce que j'ai pour
personne qui fait votre booking vous
même moment avez vous un petit courriel
tokyo qui vous en voyez où c'est
vraiment et ça ça dépend surface par les
dmc what's up des petits courriel on ne
commet un template mon leurs écrits tout
le temps vaincre la peur qu'ils ont
écrit je suis tout cas qu'on écrit
mettons aux agences tout ça fort le way
cgtu à james epeat autres mais comme ça
mais on est tellement tout occupé de
chacun notre bourgis garde si un jour ça
donne ça donne ce soir j'aimerais
l'avoir parce que cette équipe mais
habituellement tu imagines damas avoir
des sponsors sur sources - mais aucun
jeu vous aimeriez vous souvenez mais
quand je vais être pratiquée parce que
j'invite personnes maintenant voilà
pourquoi je les fais pas je suis pas
king à l'aise avec lui puis comme c'est
la première fois que j'ai fait un
podcast est lui qui m'avait invité à
faire mais c'est mon premier pas de cash
vu que ce soit lui pour fois comme une
espèce de retour d'ascenseur
mais comme j'avais deux personnes qui
ont un poids de gaza en ce moment parce
que je veux me pratiquer mes cages vont
être bonnes à n'apporter qu'un projet de
bonnes absolument abjecte non mais il ya
tellement marrer quand j'allais voir
michael biehn loges après mike zelouf ac
je m'en fiche de tout à fait ce n'est
que ouais on a parlé après quand on dit
ça mais je t'ai pas que justice turque
devant mike mais c'est un humain qui me
fascine c'est un humain comme jeux comme
world s'est dit le cheveu ras et
s'allumeront jaz un peu pris j'étais là
aussi un pic christine on voulait
tellement bien forcés à dieye marijke
irak sabine start-1 pas de caisse de
raya les bleus mike sortons devant -
mais moi je donne pas le temps de
répondre je vais juste crié comme une
marque
non vous le même parti bien sûr tout
peau
je peux l'appeler au podcast du québec
maud kaspi lui clame un voulait pas
comme burrill malaise puis rien répond
j'espère comme chez amataï tsahal a duré
quarante deux ans j'ai parié
c'était juste là tu es comme la pièce ça
bougeait plus pis moi ils me regardent
des gens sympas 15 tarmac
steph oct mais j'avais juste que c'était
martin cloutier mais c'est ça c'est que
tout était favorable c'est martin
cloutier ce comme mon grand frère martin
comme lui ai fait ma mise en scène de
mon sac mais elle lui a fait la mise en
scène m'a vraiment donné un bon coup de
pouce pour tout ce qui est humain parce
que moi je fais humour et chansons en
spectacle facilement et des demandes et
les bruits tout pour être heureux ou
immo gbit dénis ribas décrit c'est
exactement comme moi que dans le fond
maille qui m'a rassuré là dedans quand
j'ai dit tout écrit parce que moi
j'écoute ce que tu fais tu penses
toujours par un chemin différent pour te
rendre au punch tapis de mousse c'est
écrit oui puis non c'est du rodage plus
jean jeu-là compte d'une façon cela
compte d'une autre façon je raconte mon
façon puis je regarde les réactions
chaque mois ses semis un procès ni
écrire
si je suis devant maintenant une maison
de la culture que tout est favorable
pour faire de l'humour mettons dans un
volume aussi compliqué
maintenant je fais une salle plus debout
il ya de l'alcool belle ça va être plus
de musique que de blabla j'ai des beats
tout est raccourci pour les conditions
vacances estivales c'est du quatre
lignes peintes kathleen punch une
chanson comme ça ça va vite mais dans
une maison de la culture mais le plat
s'assied qu'un balcon le sage est
vraiment un est bonne répartition le
monde mes tongs et d'éric lehoux du
monde qui parle mais il fait donc sous
sa gueule ça dépend comment c'est fait
maintenant des gens qui me disaient
kwapis que le jeu peut passer par dessus
le sait vraiment nice mais quelqu'un qui
essaye juste d'être plus drôle que
touche comme
bombay merci je me rappelle pas jetée où
j'allais vraiment loin et le recul et
puis la fille à l'hôtel la gérante de
l'hôtel avait dit pis le spectacle s'est
bien passé j'ai dit oui pourquoi du bain
passent des fois on peut voir là d'une
belle game de crewe sanguin elle m'a
répondu ah ouais ouais
comment était il ya eu un éclair pas ce
qu'est le mouvement 20 des fonds s'est
amusé le mettons mat in fine notre jeu
ça me fait penser à une toune mélange
pauvre à chanter a capella qui viennent
me chercher le stenting de céline je
commence mon anglais fait qu'amener yb a
tout pigé regarde le monde je sais pas
c'est quoi parole rendu l'eau des vagues
lors on arrête là tu sarrybiens go il
crie mon année si on se connaît la boîte
et j'ai cassé mon année 6 et puis je
suis vraiment en mode dit si tu veux
simplement quand je fais cela mon
essence et l'huile car ils sont plus mal
à l'aise pour moins 8,5 les initiales il
connaît tout juste faute se comprennent
c'est que moi j'habite pas ici tu le
sais pas ce qui m'excite c'est ma
cousine qui tous ma soeur mais c'est sa
belgique qui trouvait le matin j'en
revenais pas que la madame à l'irlande
10 6 x bello mch relève tabarnak blaye à
naples au bourgneuf à ce match là on
appelle papa un tas de mechta que
vincent sera ci sera soit web puis la
pelouse se termine puis le jeu laisse un
malade je laisse ça vide
puis j'ai regardé le ski est vraiment
cool c'est qu'on n'est pas dans votre
partie de famille le lieu est né ce
titre est déjà loin on vient d'avoir la
dengue des caves
ça avait par rapport auquel le ya
quelqu'un qui connaît quelqu'un claude
s'élève que m'ont applaudi ce lot et
comme c'est quoi ça c'est bon vous je
suis facilement déconcentrée après ceux
qui ont acheté ou perdons en tout cas
pourquoi ça m'arrive des fois mais rome
pour voir le monde
sinon c'est notamment d'un mariage des
petits bouts des toiles le monde se
mette en avant de la scène pis maristes
oui il a adouci viennent se marier avant
et viennent se demander qui était juste
vraiment comme la scène était très très
hot le souhaitent une maison de la
culture fait il paie comme l'eau mais la
tension ça faisait quand même le monde
quand avant la viande une encore plus
craints qui est parti du fond de la
salle a dévalé la badea de secourues a
couru jusqu'à assène affaissé saah sah
une panne faisait des signes en voulant
dire comme il se mérite
babouche comme d'un petit but le double
à mener j'arrête de chardy joue avec et
si tu veux je fasse mouche mouche angle
je sais quoi je pas prêtes - quelle
façon nous appelons ça claude soula
exactement à fait clair la fille a fait
- oui c'est comme un couple cash qui
l'ayant like hell partie assez loin la
tuna finish bambins voulez vous je la
refais rester parce que comme km du
monde n'ont pas vécu le moment qui ont
fait que je les ai faites puis après ça
y est les photographies et une info taux
est un rude et quand j'étais tellement
tabarnak après je regarde et je le
respecte a pris de notes faut plus
jamais dit pas cependant show gens ça se
fait juste poule gens à limite le petit
mariage de ses quilles où ils sont
maladroits mais m'ont pas déranger tant
qu ils y ont fait leurs enfants et à des
signes de détresse l'agent quelqu'un a
été tout elle se marie ce mon père
m'avait m'avait payé des billets pour
aller voir d'aunis de yang au grand
théâtre de nice de yang
l'ancien chanteur de stx qui comme
reconnu pour sa voix le trépied
sa voix puissante puis il y avait un
monsieur dans l'audience qui à chaque
fois qu il note que dennis deyoung pneus
le monsieur voulait tenir la note plus
longtemps que lui
puis un cri
piste est constamment les gens pendant
ce weed madame blue line et tient une
note qui évoque une longue puis c'est
comme le sport ou est-ce qu'il ya tjrs
imputé met on en oublie dans tout les
albums live de stx ce moment l'oeil et
comme epic parce que denis zion qui
tient tout le temps cette note leur
footing longtemps en live le monsieur
plus longtemps que lui mais genre t'es
fier je l'entends talent tu écoutes le
show mais tentant aussi les studios
qu'il était tentant savoie qui comme os
il essaie de tenir la chipie tout le
long de schull donné d'ailleurs il veut
tellement facile et scor dit non non les
musicales souvent j'en mets ton
chantelat lanotte a fait place à la
notamment mais y'a du monde car tient
plus longtemps
je continue à tout imprévu
quand les gens aillent c'est le fun à
vous les connaissez vraiment bien comme
il ya comme un breton
ouais mais c'est toujours dans la blague
que d'autres parce que moussa me go sam
attendait juste ce qui sur une personne
toutes les autres ont payé pour être
avec moi je veux juste casser la
personne qui gâche le moment aux autres
manie encore une maison de la culture et
le monde tout à scipion une famille un
par 4 enfants sortent beaucoup de son
beau tout le monde et tout le monde
tellement les doutes mais d'un ranger
comme proche de la scène
je vais apprendre à tourner je fais
deuxième tonnes après je regarde
j'écoute et je table la personne c'est
juste que vous cachez un bloc complet
des gens qui ont payé le même prix que
vous faites vous voyez il ya aussi un
espèce de la sécurité maintenant dans
les spectacles parce que les gens lisent
vraiment des gens qu'il fait ça touche
les gens essaient de monter ça c'est une
pouliche qui bien ouais c'est vraiment
les salles de brousse et de l'anxiété
pour moi c'est comme et en même temps je
vois leur panier a annoncé fin octobre
s'il fait une petite mais parlant
chanteuse essaie de me toucher de me
panier chaque fois des fois je vois même
pas à gauche parce qu'il ya du monde à
gauche sont trop un temps je me tenir
plus à droite le parce que sinon une
pause pipi
tous les répondants foule j'ai fait du
ballet surfing en première année mais
maintenant je peux plus faire c'est la
première année spectacle j'avais aussi
un bientôt je me promenais dérange et
puis parler au monde puis quand je
faisais de l'impro avec les gens je peux
plus parce que ça commençait que les
gens se lever puis courait après mois a
appris pendant spectacle j'en ai moins
je pense pas que j'en manquais bon temps
fou des fois tu vois mes temps et joe
jackson témoin parce qu'il peut décorer
le mettons des rôles qui étanche aux
playes s'approche de la fois le plus
beau du monde qui toujours partout le
pluie et regarde juste comme qui y voit
quasiment à travers une arrière garde
pas le du monde sont justes comme face à
face avec lui le lit regarde
on regarde à travers réseau puisque
touché partout puis quand tu as besoin
d'être crise une espèce de mécanismes de
défense le rôle parce que c'est fou des
gens qui mettons tous les justes tout un
regard perçant tabernacle d'hôpital à
gens regardent plus lui parce que non
mais pas à ce point là c'est juste que
les yeux c'est la porte de laon chaque
mois maintenant religion ils me
reconnaissent ils me regardent c'est la
mort de ma drummeuse est très spirituel
aussi pas dire on regarde quand
l'exposant rang des magasins qui venait
de fumer
rendu là parce que ça fait d'être un
tabarnak meiway des fois le jeu en
magasin un répit demain une jambe parce
que c'était cassé en fait semaine ça en
fait à ma grand mère on est loin de
salles à saint rémy puis comme on les
sent trahie jolie brune on est vraiment
beaucoup fait que ça prend deux salles
puis avait des parts et de bureaux des
jeux il y avait des parties de famille
ou site asos à la bâtisse puis je
pouvais plus aller aux toilettes parce
que les enfants que les parents puissent
ces falaises prendre des photos ou
encore dans cinq ans a été la partie je
voulais mon analyse jean jé marché la
taille par fait baisser jusqu'à mon
genre je comprends mais tout pour les
choletais quand même la chance d comme
ceux de paniers reste est fade et quand
même gros show qu'il a tant fait eric
boury jacquier c'est pas un peu
d'ambiance ou genre que j'aurai du hall
avec une chanteuse que celle au pied des
petites disputes à terre puis jean rède
à boîtier cléry pigeard c'est tout
croche le soleil en effet temps nestea
puis les messieurs tu joues je me
souviens actes et watts et ron wood
tonnes dans l'action de jouer deux ans
et demi car l'éducation livre dur ton
art leurs garanties
moussilou lakhdar ok le chat fête
continue alors là vous hais
ha ut manga chez nous après c'est quoi
ce sinistre à une takamine une igname à
rabat ok est-ce que je fasse les backs
tard - map eguiguren au monde
pis je dirais la ville mais je m'en
rappelle pauvres pourraient c'était un
local conçu pour faire de la danse facs
étaient toutes des miroirs des leçons
puis là tout le mur en avant c'était des
vitres c'était une belle vitrine c'est
la piste n 5 qui construit pour le
spectacle qui a précédé fonds factice et
des jeunes 5 o'clock au club quand ils
marchent dessus puis c'était ça c'est au
fond du monde piste du monde qui
connaissent encore be le moins ces deux
parties à un trac qu'avant d'entre elles
j'ai hâte de la blouse musiciens qui
rockent pas mal plus que les autres
c'est fac on se donne c'est bourré je
crie 15 20 piges son roman ni
l'organisateur du spectacle arrive à un
pied de huy gens pendant pendant sept ou
non que moi je suis fort king dedans
chante est à un pied ne m'appartient
papier palatin bien devant moi je me dis
mais qu'est ce qu'il fit [ __ ] suis
comme j'en revenais pas chanter puis je
la regarde en voulant du blick en ligne
vraiment rester lauréats la soutenait
mon regard
le cheminent à tous de jurançon bonne
quinzaine de semaines microsoft m je me
retourne en donne le papier piste écrite
bien dit que le propriétaire du ford
f-150 va se faire remorquer si une
bouche pour son véhicule alors même si
vous êtes j'étais un super g dans le
pari je supporte seul ton message met en
avant dans la loge qu'il a tout à
légende clavien bois al oula papin comme
va leur coûter un embryon le faux-pas
faut pas prendre un nom il faut pas
avoir la grosse tête les petits c'est
quelqu'un dans le milieu artistique que
pas la grosse tête c'est fort kent -
tabarnak fabuleux juste parce qu'un mot
de ce jeu m'a gonflé à l'hélium je pète
à cochons j'avais eu droit je le batte
avec domino a drummer c'était comme
madame faudrait il faudrait partir
roskam tout est un petit milieu où tout
le monde se connaît madame il faudrait
quitter garde
après ça le line up de photos il n'y a
pas de madame de jean 70 ans à la
propriétaire du bar du village n'ont
hélas mais mon choix c'est peut être
remorqué pour être dans le line up puis
elle essayait d'arrêter les gens trop
saoul
oui vous avez bien entendu elle essayait
d'aller la légère au prix auteur du bord
dans lequel tu joues et non non ce n'est
pas elle était comme plus à arue
moustène local de danse et le telle est
l eau puis à voulait aller les prix ça
j'ai jamais vu ça les gens aiment ça
diminue leur pc sont énormes et apprenez
la face le ps qui est ce qui a été en
production laitière est ce qu'ils
étaient lors ce qu'on peut appeler une
montée de ferme ou n'importe quoi selon
j
la méthode proposée est arrivé en moins
j'ai averti mange des mythes comme
touché a fini par un billet bulls en
effet si elle essayait de mai à l'été
puis j'écris avec 70 mcaleese me donne
une poussée j'ai crié après
l'organisation je ne peux pas croire que
personne ne pas faire de plainte pour
agression sexuelle
non mais c'est vrai je suis en train de
baiser avec sur le sands a était pas
après tout ce qu'on a je faisais que je
pense que t'as jamais vécu une geek
brune comme si ce n'était peut-être déjà
joué là c'est tout le monde passe par le
genre
ma belle pas de calais s'est infléchie
mao c'est comme un instit caracas
mais toutes les missions m'ont dit qu'à
maison je vois texter match je vais
demander que savourer à perdre le seoul
est crack house en mai mais le petit
dire quelle auto bleue il faut qu'ils
déplacent en auto ça arrive mais ça peut
te non c'est qu'elle est dans la pause
voire être cirage pour ta femme avis
s'il ya danger pouvant être aussi ma vie
s'est jouée billère depuis annoncé
laitiers samedi c'est encore beaucoup en
aigu
enfin - ouais j'en fais mon métier c'est
le temps des failles déjà pas d'écho
repos ils vont avoir des tirages mais
ont des cadeaux de presse j'avais écouté
des mariages en breton j'ai déjà entendu
l'histoire de même et moi y'a un mariage
qui voulait compter sur le cas ça me
retombe et je peux résumer vraiment
rapidement on joue pis moi c'était c'est
moi qui a mené mon enquête de son qui
fait qu'on finisse tôt mais le litige et
continue ce sont donc elles sont faites
moi faut que j'attende parler comme ça
c'est bien pour démonter plus lourdement
chargés chacun de l'avenue je vois la
mariée sortir qui me fit savoir si bolat
en gros oui c'est vrai je t'ai le sx est
bon sens quasiment 5 km où il faut tail
pour la vie photo jm ont tous deux
intérêt à oui parce que c'est
l'appartement de mongols vous allez de
ben hur entre la langue des trous d'un
monde c'était cris des enfants ces
méchancetés watch la soirée et à bouffe
par tous ses contours gens c'est
vraiment trash la house alors qu'on fait
le parti après le show non non on est
parti mais c'est clairement tu es moche
grâce
frenchy abords de la tente
ol a varié avec son ami de file le
mariage comme ses fans le métier plus
frenchie des filles genre mais près de
sur le ton mariage avec lille dont
l'homme de tête
mais comme je n'ai entendu ce conte
raconté ce texte répond cette série
comme j'en suis parti dans les deux cas
qui lisent vu le tpo était pour ruiner
pour autant mais je pense quitter dubaï
déçu pour tes loin des pics mais sinon
il y avait qu un jouet c'est ce avant je
ne sais toujours 4 quand on restait au
deuxième
c'est un genre d des ghettos de même le
train jardet d'apartés creusot vous
allez avoir n'a pas compté deuxième
balle en main qui me disait ma
production jésus quand ils nous
fournissent quelque chose là on s'en
crée son vol hôtel parce que tu sais
jamais quoi ça m'intéresse pas quand
l'autre jour en italie mais c'était
quand même autre mais c'est parce qu'on
y système prend une douche comme un
appart
on est comme deux par chambre où j'ai ma
chance ici dans les deux par chambre
monde était à domicile divin comme le
fallait comme qu'on fasse une rotation
de la douche en mai matin mais au moins
tu es rendu à un endroit où est ce que
tu peux tu peux te permettre de faire ce
vraiment un métier c'est à cette année
le booking ça va vraiment comme plus le
réseau de grosses salles puis moi mon
dada j'adore ce faire des versions
acoustiques aussi fait que j'aimerais
ceux éventuellement faire une tournée on
the side des petites salles que l'homme
qu'ils ont une espèce de cash et cool de
150 200 places pis on se pète le show
acoustique ça c'est votre cochon
acoustique c'est tout la même gamme ou
s'est passé à gaza caustique et en
acoustique domicile cannes
oh mais c'est fou mais la première fois
j'aurais fait si on avait accepté
je savais même beau monde sont en fait
on sera costaud que j'ai fait c'est
parce que ma première
moi j'ai vu que tu es en actions à créer
puis arrive la bouille 50 personnes
c'est vraiment un show laurent intime
dassin tabouret un tapis avec des
petites lumières je me prenais mon
guitariste mad ramos qui était sur
garonne puis c'est la première fois de
ma vie que je réalisais vraiment les
paroles d'une de mes chansons
bah oui c'est ça que ça fait chanter
puis je m'entends pas démentant pas
d'habitude mais j'étais comme m
violences conjugales puis un show de
tellement l'adrénaline peut-être une
séquence dans tes oreilles il faut
poursuivre le bench plus mécanique
organique cpie vue qui est au début du
show le stress n'est pas encore descendu
j'habite - les chansons l'acheter comme
cette chanson c'est le disait avec ce
qu'elle faisait au chaos depuis la
guitare acoustique en ligne voire
complètement différent ça reste dans
l'esprit de ce qu'on disait plutôt de
garder ce projet en 5.1 prétention de
feu puis vraiment justement le cacher
c'est vraiment vraiment pas que je
l'aimerais sommes pas tant et rim font
tourner à conséquences seraient du game
2 de faire des shows de stand up stand
up je ne sais pas bonjour les phares à
15 minutes mais ça je vais l'essayer la
fille justement de du bordel m'avait dit
viens te le potentiel pour les gens qui
avaient fait le podcast avec moi le gpat
j'ai pas le temps de masse et de décrire
un quinze minutes seulement tout qu'est
ce que je fais c'est propulsé par de la
musique après tu fais hors contexte
contexte je sais pas quel point ce
serait pertinent
puis
là j'ai pas le temps de faire ça puis je
peins honnêtement la seule raison pour
laquelle je ferai pas de la tournée je
sens les mots c'est que je finirais par
me tire une balle dans le casse d'être
seul en tout genre comme j'ai dit j'ai
besoin je trouve les outils pour être
bien en tournée puis mon band est
vraiment là pour ça pour m'appuyer thema
drummer c'est ma meilleure amie
c'est comme quand je finis en boule sa
côte nord dans mon lit temps plein c'est
elle qui est la vache à lait camp d'été
c'est plus rofl qu'est-ce que qu'est ce
qu'on souhaite pour la suite des choses
perdurer dans le temps jusque dans la
foi je pense que c'est le ca fait ça va
faire un an qu'on s'est vu la première
fois un petit peu moins qu'un an puis
clairement que très perdurer dans cette
année on passe à autre chose
on n'arrête pas de faire des jokes - du
mat le monde n'est pas non mais si j'ai
eu un félix plus en fait cela m'est
chère à québec j'ai eu deux plaques de
l'a 10 dans le fond c'est le gala des
radios ça s'appelle le gala de l'adisq
ou 6 mai pour les radios ces
dénominations des stations dénomination
d'animateur
puis j'ai eu deux plats que mon album a
été plus de 100 semaines au top palmarès
à 10 kilos c'était le premier album dans
les bus coincés fucked up ses mélodies
gersois félix gers où les deux plaques
de l'adisq pour lee van peel je vais
avoir un disque adore aussi on m'a
annoncé en fin de semaine
justement merci fax et comme le g1
espèces d'armor avec toutes les prix
2010 2019 c'était une bonne année c'est
comme si le monde qu'ils chérissent leur
vieux souvenir
mais j'ai 60 ans je regardais mon
armoire de 1 2900 marchand estimons à
faire chaud de belleval toi d'abord pas
si j'aimerais ça parce que ouais j'ai
écouté
on est attentif bourrine mon vent dans
le micro j'écoutais edward norton qui
est un acteur qui a joué en fait le sait
lequel c'est l'acteur principal le
narrateur qu'il fait là brad pitt mais
blanc mais il aime et 10 m qui s'est
assis à la première du film il était en
arrière la salle comble mais la première
médiatique dans l'ariège la salle comble
mais c'est à côté de brad pitt
puis le film fini puis ceux ci sont si
sa version la banque brad et s'est
tourné vers lui puis 10 y en a pas
beaucoup dans une carrière d comme ce
genre après avoir vu la première fois
qu'ils voyaient le film aidé il y en a
beaucoup dans une carrière d comme ceux
hong sang soo est une coupe d'autres 10
me en a pas beaucoup
comme en réalisant ce que fait jacques
et comme l'on on vienne vivre de quoi
qui en aura pas beaucoup ils vont en
avoir d'autres mais soit fier de ce que
tu viens de faire parce que celui le
genre tu le vends ta poche le genre
celui l'oeil à exister dans ta carrière
tu as fait ce film fait pas partie
maintenant peu importe qu est ce que tu
fais ça tu as des deux meilleurs ça peut
être moins bons d'offre sur 10 mais ça
met la barre haute à ses hôtes le
trophée le physique c'est vraiment cool
j'adore je suis comblé mais dans no 1
dans ta vie c'est le premier c'est comme
j'en aurais peut-être pas d'autres
auxquelles il faut que je sorte quelque
chose comme un fardeau on doit laisser
la question je te pose et je pense quand
on est pas encore mais c'est comme cette
grosse tu depuis avant longtemps faire
des vidéos quand tu es en tout le temps
c'est puis j'ai l'impression que ce qui
va faire la différence
non je cracher sur tout le monde qui
m'ont donné le premier push the name et
des traditionnels j'ai besoin de faire
des vidéos où j'aime tellement ça tu
sais que tu es fans sont aussi fidèles
aussi intense si je meurs sécurité ma
première et deuxième années une vidéo sa
liste
acheter comme je me déguisais je faisais
beaucoup d'humour après ça j'ai commencé
à mettre un peu de chance on puisse
faire face caméra avec du jamc à
décortiquer les sujets puis le mani je
me suis comme perdue là dedans savait
plus où aller
- le monde qui parle pour rien après ça
je tombais dans le blog l'année passée
parce que j'ai commencé la tournée j'en
ai les gens en coulisses avec moi même
année ça va faire son temps ça aussi que
je veux dire un spectacle pour moi c'est
différent chaque fois mais pour les gens
on arrive on mange sans tchèque à
présent c'est le show syfy est toujours
la même chose mais le jamais les gens
jouent dans les spectacles plus
importante jamais tant le spectacle à
saint jean ou des trucs comme ça je l'aï
jamais mais je les amène pas tout le
spectacle
ça serait plus qu'il peut ouais c'est ça
pihem espèces je voulais pas dire qu'il
ya des spectacles plus importants que
d'autres c'est juste comme des plus
grosses mais quoi exactement
pour que les gens ça les intéresse plus
maintenant pis là c'est le jeu tombe
plus dans le pot 2 gars parce que c'est
moins compliqué le montage c'est encore
drôle vue que j'ai plusieurs plans d'eau
puis moussa rôle pan allemand
c'est comme au montage mais
mouais je ne compte plus les ans
beaucoup métis continue parce je vois
pas pourquoi ça fais ton public doit
rester là puis en tant que toi tu
continues j'imagine en toiture la cia ce
merci les gars merci d'abord et à toi ça
me fait plaisir
hier très cool